jetzt alter leute ich habe schon eine halbe stunde was erzählt gerade also
mindestens mindestens drei minuten oder so ich habe schon ich wundere mich die
ganze zeit warum keiner was sagt alter ich habe übelst geheult und mich
entschuldigt und so apology video gemacht und keiner hat gehört es ist da
los das hätte ich nicht gedacht das war
garantiert wieder in windows update okay leute aber ernsthaft da muss ich
jetzt alles noch mal sagen also lass mal überlegen nicht dass ich irgendwas
vergessen habe also es gehört nein nein nein es als erstes was ich gesagt habe
ist ich habe den stream angefangen mit leute ich bin wieder gesund ich habe
die letzten zwei wochen immer so gucken ob ich jetzt zusammen kriegt ich habe
die letzten zwei wochen nicht viel geschrieben
hier schleimhautentzündung im magen und alles letzte woche hätte ich schon ein
bisschen schrieben können habe ich mir aber gedacht ich mache mal ein bisschen
langsam und ich musste mmo kreise greifen da ist gerade pvp event muss ich
nachher auch wieder aber und das wollte ich sagen weil ich mich selbst ein
bisschen geärgert hat und ihr wisst normalerweise geht mir das geht mir das
voll am arsch vorbei aber ich muss jetzt trotzdem mal sagen ich gelobe besserung
ich werde in nächster zeit wieder mehr streamen denn es gibt auch einige sachen
auf die ich richtig bock habt zu streamen aber ich hatte in letzter zeit
einfach nicht die notice ich körperliche geistige motivationsverfassung
wie auch immer man das nennen mag aber und jetzt warum ich meine vom gestartet
habe ist ich wollte además machen euch was zeigen was wir unbedingt stream so
wollen ist striWindes ins universum und zwar ich habe mir bei den china-chinesen
bestellt die nene und ihm ist das nicht ist so wie ich sage ich hätte ohne
probleme eigentlich mehr streamen könne auch letzte woche schon neuland der extra streamår
des 제가 user wo heiser im managerium in담adas die um mobile platform miteinander
mal eben alsoゆpe mir Ads oder ich bin neoreilly destoo Failover Online
ich hätte dort manchmal geblofen hat weil ich habe mich начал einematmert getЯrt haben
vorange gangen an sondern u inclined lag es ist so wie ich sage ich hätte ohne problemen eigentlich mehr streamen können auch letzte woche schon war genau wie es kam habe ich habe gerade ja
letzte Woche schon, aber
davor auch. Ich hab
echt wenig gestreamt in letzter Zeit.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Das trifft's, das trifft's ganz gut.
Wobei es gar nicht so sehr daran lag, dass
ich so wenig Bock hatte, sondern
man muss halt irgendwie gucken, dass das alles passt
und in letzter Zeit
war ich ziemlich kaputt, was so unter
der Woche arbeitsmäßig angeht.
MMO Kreiselgrind, ich spiele ja immer noch
hier Dark Freeshot.
Das ist die
beste Version, ohne Scheiß, falls das Spiel
jemand früher mal gespielt hat. Das ist die beste
Version von Dark Age of Camelot, die es je gegeben hat.
Ich weiß nicht,
wie es ein ehrenamtliches
Freeshot-Team innerhalb von
zwei Jahren hinbekommt,
das Spiel besser zu machen
als live mit
sehr viel Geld über zehn Jahre.
Whatever. Also,
super nice. Zumindest
ich hab mir was bei den China-
Chinesen bestellt und das müssen
wir demnächst zusammenlöten im Stream.
Ja, übrigens hier, gut, dass du es gesagt hast.
Ich hätt's...
Ich hab mich schon als gewundert...
Warum sagt keiner was?
Das erklärt's natürlich.
So, und jetzt Arch, by the way, erstmal
Package-Updates.
Genau, und was ich euch zeigen wollte, ich hab mir was bestellt.
Und zwar, ihr wisst ja, ich hab eine
Mitsubishi
Heavy Z...
Oh...
Ever.
Aber...
Wie mal ein Lager, die ungefähr so aussieht.
Hier.
Innengeräte, das hängt draußen
an der Wand, so ähnlich. Es sieht nicht ganz
genauso aus, so ähnlich. Auch so eine ähnliche
Fernbedienung. Und ich hab im Haus
solche Geräte, solche, das ist so eine
Split-Klimaanlage, ein Teil draußen.
Dann bis zu, glaub ich, fünf Geräte
drin, wobei ich keine fünf Geräte drin hab.
Es heißt ja noch, es ist noch Zeit, das
Ganze zu erweitern. Zumindest
ich hab ein mega
nice Shit-Up-Projekt
gefunden. Wie bei Netto, genau.
Plus kleiner.
Oder bei mir ist es eher beim
Lidl. Bei mir gibt's, glaub ich, gar kein
Netto. AC, danke schön für den
Sub. Ich hab ein mega nice Shit-Up-Projekt
gefunden.
Und zwar das hier.
Der hat
eine Custom-Firmware
für den ESP32, beziehungsweise
ESP8266, das glaub ich sogar.
Ich glaub, man kann beides nehmen.
Entwickelt, womit man
alle diese Mitsubishi Heavy
Klimaanlagen steuern kann. Und meins
ist so eins hier. Also das,
was er auch hat, was auch so
geportet ist. Weil ich hab immer das Problem,
ich hab ja, ich hab hier zwei Fernbedienungen
dafür, aber jedes Mal
hab ich die irgendwo hingeschmissen
und ich find die Fernbedienung nicht. Jetzt hab ich sie
hier, ne? Jetzt liegt sie hier vor mir,
aber das sind entweder die Batterien all
oder ich hab die Fernbedienung irgendwie hingeschmissen
und ich bin ja schon seit Jahren am überlegen,
wie ich meine Klimaanlage
gescheit in meine Heimautomatisierung
reinbekomme. Ich hab schon mehrere Sachen
ausprobiert. Ich hatte mal so ein
Broadlink IR auf
Firefox.
Ich hatte mal so ein Broadlink IR.
Also eine kleine schwarze Kiste,
wo man
Infrarotsachen schicken kann,
weil die Fernbedienung ist natürlich
letztendlich eine Infrarotfernbedienung.
So ein kleines, kleines, rundes Ding hatte ich da.
Ja, fuck.
Hat nicht alles unterstützt.
Die Klimaanlage ist relativ gut
customizable. Also kann's,
ich zeig, ihr guckt euch mal die,
wenn ihr hier euch die Fernbedienung
anguckt, die kann man nämlich noch
ausklappen. Der Klima-Hero.
Ich hoffe, die Fernbedienung ist hier
einzeln drauf. Also die Fernbedienung,
die kann man hier unten noch ausklappen und da sind hier unten
noch viel mehr Knöpfe drauf. Hier unten
sind nochmal doppelt so viel Knöpfe drunter
unter der, unter der Klappe,
wie man da eigentlich
sieht.
Und da kann man wirklich, ja,
äh, nee.
Meins hat mehr Knöpfe.
Nee.
Ja, so ungefähr sieht meine Fernbedienung aus.
So, und da kann man enorm viel
einstellen dran. Also,
du kannst links, rechts,
vorne, hinten, automatisch,
äh, kurz,
tief, bis auf eine gewisse Grad
runterkühlen, dann, äh, in Lautlos-
Modus schalten, Lüfter-Speed
von Hand. Den Modus kannst du umschalten
zwischen, äh,
einfach nur ein bisschen Luft umwälzen.
Ähm, das ist
so ein Pollenfilter-Modus, kannst du da
irgendwie einschalten. Dann kannst
du heizen, kühlen,
und ich glaub den Pollenfilter-Modus.
Irgendwie die vier Sachen sind's.
Und Auto, Auto noch, genau.
Kannst du zwischen umschalten,
und ganz viel Zeug noch. So, gut,
ich mein, diese Timer-Funktionalität
verwende ich nicht. Äh, Silent ist
auch nice, wenn's, äh,
da ist wirklich nur ganz minimal zum,
zum, äh, Temperatur halten und so.
Zumindest, du kannst sehr viel customizen an der
Klimaanlage,
wie du das haben willst, und
die ganzen Infrarot-
Funk-Dinger haben das alles nur super
rudimentär implementiert.
Ich weiß nicht, ich mag die
Soft-Dualt-Musik nicht. Bin ja irgendwie
der Einzige, aber, äh, ich fall
den Soundtrack nicht so
nice. So, zumindest
ist das hier alles nicht richtig implementiert.
Da kannst du dann teilweise nur an, aus
Stufe einstellen und nicht links, rechts.
Dann hatte ich was eigenes
gebaut. Wir haben das ja sogar mal hier
Woop Lords TV, wir haben ja
sogar mal im Stream was gebaut.
Klima...
Titel...
Hier. Klimaanlagensteuerung
haben wir ja auch mal probiert zu bauen.
Weiß nicht, ob ich da sogar mal
ein, äh, Kamera vorne hatte.
Ja, also, alles
irgendwie nicht so geil. So.
Und das hier unterstützt mehr oder
weniger alles das, was man haben will. Zumindest
das, was ich auf den ersten Blick hier schon mal sehe.
Kannst dann ausschalten und
du kannst alle Modi ordentlich durchschalten.
Du kannst die, die
Geschwindigkeit und du kannst auch
die, wobei ich hier noch nicht so genau checke, ob man auch
vorne und hinten einstellen kann, die Richtung
der Lamellen in der Klimaanlage
einstellen. So, und das Ding ist,
das ist eine Custom-Firma von ESP
2866. Das
Problem ist bloß, wie kriegst
du den ESP 2866
an die Klimaanlage dran?
Und da gibt es hier ein paar Bilder.
Ihr seht das, so sieht die
Klimaanlage auf und da kann man das reinstecken.
Das Ding ist nur, ihr seht, da steckt kein
ESP 2866 direkt in der
Klimaanlage, sondern da brauchst du
ein Board dafür. Und dieses
Board hat er hier auch schon die
Schematics am Start.
Hier.
Und so ein Board habe ich
mir bestellt. Fünf Stück
habe ich mir Custom anfertigen lassen.
Bei unserem China-Chinesen
Platinenfertiger
schlechthin. JLC
nee, JLCPCB.
Welche Protokoll die sprechen? Irgendein
Mitsubishi-Protokoll, keine Ahnung.
Achso, SPI sprechen
die, aber da drüber irgendein
Special Mitsubishi hast du nicht gesehen.
Zumindest ist das gar nicht so einfach.
Ja, also hier habe ich mir so eine extra
Platine hochgeladen.
Ich habe im Endeffekt die
Schematics hier hochgeladen und
oder wie man das auch immer nennt.
Ja, wie heißt denn sowas hier?
Die Layouts quasi.
Für die Platine hochgeladen
und die Custom fertigen jetzt für mich
fünf Platinen
hiervon.
Die Elektronikteile habe ich mir
auch schon bestellt.
Wild, was es so für Firmen gibt.
Alter, das ist ein riesen Ding hier.
Ja.
Die machen glaube ich erst seit ein paar Jahren
auch für private Leute.
Das ist so ein riesen China-Chinesen
Halbleiter-Chip
Platinen.
Ohja, wichtig.
Ein
JLCPCB.
Ja, das ist ein riesen Ding und da kannst du deine Sachen hochladen
und ratet mal,
was das kostet, fünf Stück
Custom für mich anfertigen zu lassen.
Es ist viel billiger als man
inklusive Versand, inklusive Versand.
2,50, nein, nein, nein, nein.
20 Euro.
20 Dollar.
Ziemlich gut geraten.
Wenn ich 100
bestellt hätte oder 50 oder 20
wäre es wahrscheinlich anteilmäßig
noch billiger geworden.
Aber überlegt euch mal, 20 Dollar
inklusive Versand
für Custom
gefertigte Platinen.
Was ich natürlich noch machen musste, ich musste dann hier bei
bei Völkner habe ich das bestellt.
Normalerweise bestelle ich das
so Elektronikteile
wie, ähm, wie heißen sie? Konrad
und, oh, wie heißt der andere?
Wenn ich den Namen höre, fällt es
mir wieder ein.
Reichelt, Reichelt, genau.
Ja, ja.
Reichelt war das.
Mauser, ja, Mauser habe ich auch schon mal bestellt.
DigiKey habe ich noch nie bestellt.
Zumindest habe ich jetzt bei Völkner bestellt, weil
die hatten alles da,
was man braucht. Ja, man braucht hier so
ein paar Dinger, man braucht, ähm,
gut, den Controller
habe ich schon, wir brauchen Spannungswandler, wir brauchen den
passenden Stecker vorne dran, ein Levelshifter,
das ist ganz wichtig, weil
die Klimaanlage liefert 12 Volt, mit 12
Volt grillst du dein, deine, ähm,
Microcontroller-Elektronik.
Levelshifter, ein
Kondensator. Alter, Leute,
ich weiß nicht, was es mit diesem Wort ist.
Es ist für mich unglaublich
schwierig, die
englischen Elektronikteile
im Kopf hinzubekommen auf Deutsch.
Und wenn ich sie dann in
in Deutsch im Kopf habe,
fallen mir die englischen Begriffe nicht mehr ein.
Kondensator, Alter.
Jetzt, ich wusste eben noch
das englische Wort, da musste ich kurz überlegen,
wie heißt der Kram auf Deutsch?
Und jetzt habe ich das deutsche Wort im Kopf, äh, Capacitor,
genau, jetzt fällt mir das englische Wort nicht mehr ein.
Können die das nicht
irgendwie, könnten die das nicht irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, ähnlich nennen?
Das, was ich das merken kann.
Ich meine, Widerstand
und Resistor, das geht ja noch irgendwie, ja,
Resist, Widerstand, aber Kondensator
und Capacitor, das kriege ich im Kopf,
da fällt mir das immer nicht hin.
Und Levelshifter, habe ich gar keine
Ahnung, wie das auf Deutsch heißt.
Ähm,
Spannungsniveauangleicher
oder so, ich habe absolut,
wie, was heißt Levelshifter auf
Deutsch?
Wir fragen mal.
Wir fragen mal Amazon.
Amazon
Pegelwandler.
Ja, Level, Pegelwandler.
Leute, ja.
Braucht man auch.
Man braucht das, dass man die
5 Volt auf 3,3 Volt
kriegt, also im Prinzip hier
gehen dann die 12 Volt rein von
der Klimaanlage, wird auf 5.
5 geht in
Input für den Microcontroller und
für die Pins braucht man aber 3,3
Volt. Zumindest, ich hatte
ursprünglich vor, ich habe auch schon hier mal
ein Breadboard liegen und so eine,
wie heißt das so, Lochplatine
und so, ich wollte das eigentlich mir selbst zusammenlöten.
Auf so einer Platine, beziehungsweise erst mal
aufs Breadboard draufstecken, aber
das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen eklig,
weil die Bauteile
echt suboptimal sind, um so
2D-Layouts zu bauen.
Guckt, der Ground ist beispielsweise
hier in der Mitte, du brauchst hier zweimal in der Mitte
Ground, dann einmal hier an
3,3 Volt vom Controller, dann
hier an die 5 Volt, das ist super eklig
auf so einer 2D
Platine zu routen, wo man nur
rechteckig gescheit
löten kann. Also Sack. Deswegen habe
ich mich dazu entschieden,
einfach die Platine mir anfertigen zu lassen
von den China-Chinesen. Zumindest, ihr müsst
euch mal vorstellen, 20
Dollar inklusive Versand,
das ist super nice, oder?
Ja, die Bauteile insgesamt haben mich nochmal
irgendwie 30 Euro oder so gekostet, da war das
der größte Batzen der Versand.
Weil es irgendwie 6 Euro, 5 Euro,
50 oder so DHL-Versand gekostet hat.
Wie lange hat das
gedauert? Es ist noch nicht da, es ist noch nicht da.
Deswegen sage ich ja, das müssen wir demnächst zusammenlöten
im Stream. Es ist noch nicht da.
Also ich habe bestellt mit
DHL Worldwide Express.
Gibt es da Probleme mit dem Zoll?
Ich hatte bisher noch nie Probleme
aus China, was zu bestellen mit dem Zoll.
Und die sagen auch im Checkout, dass sie sich
um alle Zollsachen kümmern.
Also, ich habe bestellt
am...
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob am Donnerstag oder am
Freitag.
Ich glaube am Freitag erst.
Die Platine ist schon fertig und in
der Post. Die haben 24 Stunden
Fertigungsgarantie. Du lädst da deine
Files hoch. Im Prinzip lädst du dir das hier runter.
Lädst das bei denen auf der Seite hoch.
Ja, musst du dich einloggen, habe ich jetzt hier nicht.
Du lädst das hier hoch.
Und dann prüfen die erstmal,
ob die Platine fertigbar ist.
Könnte ja sein, dass du irgendwie Lücken drin hast, sodass das
nicht gedruckt werden kann und alles.
Und 24 Stunden, innerhalb von 24
Stunden fertigen die deine Platinen. Das ist bei
denen eh alles automatisiert.
Und dann packen sie es in die Post. Und es liegt jetzt schon
in der Post. Es ist aktuell gerade
am Flughafen in
Shanghai oder
Hongkong. Moment, lass mich mal kurz
gucken. Ich habe hier die Sand...
Ähm... Hongkong.
Hongkong.
China People's Republic. Alles klar.
In Hongkong ist es gerade.
Es wurde gesehen am 28.
April
um 11.05 local time.
Okay. 11.05
Hongkong time
to CEST.
Ah, heute Nacht. Okay.
Heute Nacht um 5.05 Uhr
ist mein Paket in Hongkong angekommen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Chinesen arbeiten am
Sonntag. Ob die
Sachen transportieren am Sonntag.
Wenn die Sachen transportieren am
Sonntag, besteht
theoretisch die Möglichkeit,
dass es am Montag schon
kommt. Aber ich persönlich tippe auf
Mittwoch, weil Dienstag Feiertag
ist. Ja.
Du musst da bestimmte EU-Dinge
wählen. Wat?
Was ist das
für eine Platine?
Das ist von einem Projekt auf
GitHub, was man, ich zeig's dir,
was man in seine Klimaanlage
einbauen kann.
Mittwoch ist Feiertag?
Oh, habe ich mich vertan? Nee, oder?
Ach nee,
tatsächlich. Mittwoch ist Feiertag.
Äh, wie mache ich den nächsten Monat?
Bin ich zu doof für...
So?
Man muss auch nicht alles
unbedingt mit der Shell machen, oder?
Ah.
Okay.
Dann habe ich
Mist erzählt.
Mittwoch ist Feiertag.
Tatsächlich.
Ja, korrekt.
Dann, ähm...
Dann kommt das, denke ich
mal, am Dienstag
an, vermutlich.
Schauen wir mal.
Zumindest, wie gesagt, das ist eine Platine,
die man in seine Klimaanlage einbauen kann.
So. Und damit kann man seine Klimaanlage
übers WLAN steuern und braucht nicht mehr diese
komische Fernbedienung von denen.
Ich bin schon eine ganze Weile am gucken, wie ich meine Klimaanlage
in meine Heimautomatisierung reinkriege und das
ist bis jetzt mit Abstand das
beste Projekt, was ich gesehen habe.
Ich habe da schon einiges ausprobiert, aber
da machen wir Lötchamp.
Am Mittwoch
dann am Feiertag wahrscheinlich, wenn's denn
Dienstag kommt, ja.
Da löten wir uns das Ding zusammen. Ich hoffe,
die Dinger sind in guter Qualität
in der Post am Dienstag.
So eine Platine krieg ich dann, fünf Stück.
Dann löten wir das dementsprechend zusammen.
Das dürfte nicht allzu kompliziert sein.
Einzige Sache, wo ich mir nicht ganz sicher
bin, ich bin ja so ein bisschen Elektronik-
Noob, wisst ihr ja.
Bei solchen Symbolen bin ich immer ein bisschen
aufgeschmissen, wie rum ich die Bauteile denn dann in
Wirklichkeit einbauen muss.
Also das ist aber im Prinzip auch das Einzige.
Der Rest ist easy.
Der Rest passt von den Aufdrucken her.
Ob ich einen Temperatursensor dran mach, weiß ich
auch nicht genau. Temperatursensor kommt da nie
oben dran.
Hab ich eigentlich genug.
Gut.
Und hier kommt dann der Connector dran.
Das probieren wir dann nächste Woche Mittwoch aus.
Sofern die Platinen da sind.
Aber ich bin echt
Plus ist
echt jetzt?
Moment, das guck ich mir jetzt an.
Die Elektronik-Teile hab ich nämlich schon da.
Ich wollte mir das eigentlich selbst zusammen löten.
Hatte dann aber keinen Bock,
das so 2D-mäßig zu machen.
Weil das wird viel zu groß
im Vergleich zu diesem kleinen Ding.
Wartet mal, ich guck mal. Ist das markiert mit Plus?
Wirklich?
Ist Plus markiert?
Da ist
kein Plus drauf.
Die sagen explizit
man soll Polarity
beachten.
Also ich zeig euch einfach mal
den
Moment mal Leute.
Ich zeig euch mal
den
Ist das überhaupt ein Content? Das ist gar kein Content.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Hier Artikelnummer.
0 0 0 4
4 6
2 7 7.
Äh
Nein.
Nicht wirklich?
Warum stimmt
die Artikelnummer nicht mit dem Zeug was
in dem Workshop?
Das ist kein Kondensator, ja?
Hier haben wir noch was.
Hier steht noch eine Zahl.
8 5 2 2 6 3 V
Vielleicht so?
Fuck, Alter.
Nichts dieser Nummern stimmt.
Okay, hier oben haben wir noch was.
6 5 8
4 9 0 0 2
Haben die da. Sag mal.
Die haben doch da.
Das ist wieder was anderes.
Alter, was haben die da für
Nummern drauf?
Okay, ich hab noch eins.
Ich hab noch eins.
P 0 0
Da stehen so viele Nummern drauf, Alter.
5 3 0 9 6
Alter.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ey.
Da muss doch irgendwas. Okay, ich weiß.
Ich weiß wie ich's rauskriege.
Ich hab doch hier irgendwo noch
Moment Leute. Ich weiß wie ich's rauskriege.
Ich hab doch hier noch die
Wir sind ein wenig sidetracked.
Die Nummer von dem, was ich
bestellt hab. Ich muss mal kurz in meinen E-Mails gucken.
Wo hab ich's? Hier.
Ich hab's.
Das da müsste's sein.
Ja.
Nichts von diesen Nummern steht
auf der Packung drauf, ey.
Whatever.
So. Und da ist kein Plus irgendwie
drauf. Oder seht ihr da ein Plus?
Chatgear.
Woher weiß ich jetzt?
Ich weiß, wir sind etwas
sidetracked.
Wie rum der hier drauf muss?
Wo ist denn da ein Ring?
Das da?
Oder das da? Die Kerbe meinste?
Ach, die Delle.
Die Delle ist was? Die Delle ist Plus?
Hier drauf?
Die Delle?
Ach, deswegen ist hier auch
so eine Delle.
Ach, jetzt erkenne ich das.
Das ist da aufgemalt, dass man
erkennt, in welche Richtung das muss.
Ich hab das da unten,
was hier dieses...
Dieser obere ist überhaupt nicht damit
in Verbindung gebracht, wie das Teil aussieht.
Okay. Alles klar.
Ja. Wie dem auch sei.
Das werden wir dann am...
Ich hoffe am Mittwoch. Ich hoffe bis dahin sind alle Teile da.
Wenn wir das Löt champen.
Ja.
Ich mein, die Chancen sind gut, oder?
Was denkt ihr?
Es war heute Nacht um 5 Uhr in Hongkong, das Paket.
Das heißt,
das landet jetzt im Flieger
und wird hierher geflogen.
Dann ist das...
Das ist dann montags da.
Und dann haben die Zeit,
das zu mir zuzustellen,
das Dienstag auszuliefern.
Wenn wir Pech haben,
ist es halt erst Donnerstag da.
Naja. Wie dem auch sei.
Das ist eines der Sachen,
wo ich richtig Bock habe,
das mal mit euch auszuprobieren.
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher,
ob ich euch das zeigen kann
an der Klimaanlage,
weil da liege ich mich wahrscheinlich dabei,
und das Ding einbaue.
Ah, meine Nase läuft.
Zumindest muss ich vorher
auf jeden Fall den Strom raus machen,
bevor ich an der Klimaanlage rumbau.
Gut.
Ach ja, habe ich euch schon gezeigt,
Twitter...
Wo bloß?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich vergesse ja immer,
dass Twitter jetzt richtig scheiße ist,
wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist.
Zieh eine Maske an.
Hier, die ich anziehen könnte.
Nehme ich so eine.
Man sieht das hier.
Nein, das ist mein Stream.
Ich habe doch ein Video.
Hallo Leute.
Hier, die Maske habe ich.
Ich habe so eine Maske mit so einem Keks-Face drauf.
Die kann ich theoretisch
sogar anziehen, wenn ich hier rumklettere.
An der Klimaanlage.
Zumindest Chatge,
was ich euch zeigen wollte.
Neues Low wurde erreicht.
So tief gesunken,
bin ich noch nie bisher.
88,3.
Pock, oder?
Wisst ihr, was mir gerade einfällt?
Twitter ist ja schon ein bisschen verrückt.
Ja, Twitter ist ja schon ein bisschen durch den...
geistig durch.
Ich wette mit euch,
es gibt irgendwelche Leute,
die gucken sich das Bild an und sagen,
88,
der Max sendet geheime Botschaften
von seinem Twitter-Account.
Nazi confirmed.
Oder irgendwie so was.
Die sind so durch
mittlerweile auf Twitter.
Das ist so krass kek Alu mittlerweile dort.
Das würde mich echt nicht wundern.
Ich habe das schon gelesen.
Jemand auf Twitter, dem ich folge,
der leider nicht mal auf Twitter so richtig aktiv ist,
obwohl ich auch gerne Videos geguckt habe.
Der hat 88,
nämlich sein Geburtsjahr,
in seinem Twitter-Account
drinne.
Und da kommen die Leute auch regelmäßig.
Was soll das immer mit der 88?
Ich bin 1988
geworden.
Fotosozial, du weißt Bescheid.
Wie groß ich bin?
1,74m.
Und das war ganz normal.
Das war nicht irgendwie nach dem Rennen oder sonst was.
Das war morgens,
da hatte ich glaube ich sogar noch
Unterhose und normale
Hose und so an. Also wahrscheinlich ist sogar noch
ein Ticken weniger.
Uwe69, das ist auch so ein typischer
Boomer-Nickname.
Das sind die,
das sind die, wisst ihr was?
Uwe69,
das sind die gleichen Leute,
die dann auf Facebook irgendwelche
Eierwitze zu Ostern posten.
Und ihr wisst schon,
und ihr wisst schon,
Moment,
sonst klappt das,
sonst klappt das nicht.
Und ihr wisst schon,
welche Emotes der dann da reinpostet.
Der macht Eierwitze.
Uwe69,
macht Eierwitze zu Ostern
und postet dieses Emoji dabei.
Das ist typischer, typischer Boomer-Facebook-Homer.
Ja.
So sieht's aus, 88,3.
So tief bin ich
noch nie gesunken bisher.
Also, ich mein, als ich auf die Welt
gekommen bin und so, natürlich, bevor jetzt jemand
meint, actually, das stimmt nicht,
Max, du warst schon mal leichter.
Ja, ich war schon mal leichter, aber ich war die letzten
15 Jahre
nicht mehr so leicht.
Ich würd sagen, wahrscheinlich so seit
ich, keine Ahnung,
20 oder so bin,
und jetzt bin ich 39,
war ich
nicht mehr so leicht, okay?
Und vor allem, und vor allem, jetzt kommt's ja,
nicht mehr nur nicht so leicht,
sondern so gut in Form.
Ich bin ja nicht nur leicht, ich bin ja auch noch
gleichzeitig gut in Form. Und das hatte ich
locker seit, seit der Hälfte
meines Lebens nicht mehr.
Sag mal, runden wir mal auf, ich bin seit
20 Jahren, war ich nicht
mehr so gut in Form und so leicht.
Ich bin dann morgen wieder gerannt.
Relativ,
relativ easy.
Ne, Triathlon, äh, Triathlon werde
ich nicht machen. Ich mag mittlerweile schwimmen nicht mehr.
Früher war das mein Lieblingshobby,
schwimmen zu gehen. Ich konnte auch kilometerweit
schwimmen, überhaupt kein Ding.
Aber ich hatte, ich hatte sogar die,
diese frei, nicht frei,
Freischwimmer, wie nennt man das?
Das, was es in Bronze, Silber, Gold gibt.
Ist das Freischwimmer?
Freischwimmer in Gold, gibt es sowas?
Diese, diese Abzeichen,
die man sich dann so ganz stolz auf die
Badehose nähen hat lassen von der Mutter.
Ja, schwimm habt sowas, ja.
Zumindest,
ich wollte mal, ich muss mal kurz grad in meine,
Seefährtchen hatte ich nicht, ich hatte nie
nen Seefährtchen, weil ich hatte
einen Pinguin. Ich hab das, ich hab
das in nem Offenbacher Schwimmbad gemacht, das war
im Prinzip nen Seefährtchen. Aber die
haben keine Seefährtchen vergeben, die haben
einen Pinguin vergeben.
Moment, wir gucken mal,
ob's es noch gibt. Schwimmabzeichen
Gold, jawoll.
Gold hab ich übrigens
dann nicht gemacht, Silber hatte ich.
Silber. Auf Ebay
kann man das mittlerweile kaufen, keck
weh.
Warum?
Ich mein ernsthaft, ohne Scheiß,
wenn ich sowas auf Ebay kaufe und
mir auf die Badehose montiere.
Seriously, das ist einfach gecheatet.
Das ist echt krass gecheatet.
Das Abzeichen auf Ebay
zu kaufen.
Das ist, das ist wirklich unehrenhaft schon.
Ja, ich hatte das auch immer auf der Badehose
damals.
Ja, so und
Schwimmabzeichen, ich hatte nen Pinguin.
Gibt's das noch?
Ja, sowas, genau sowas
irgendwie in der Richtung hatte ich glaub, irgendwie so.
Der sah ziemlich doof aus, aber so sah er
nicht aus, glaube so.
Irgendwie, irgendwie sowas hatte ich, Pinguin.
Bis heute gab's
kein, so und ich hab das später
gemacht bis dahin, dann hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
Deutschland, okay, Schwimmabzeichen
Silberanforderung, da muss ich mal gucken.
Das war, das war easy, ja.
Das, das war easy.
So, äh,
Seepferdchen,
Freischwimmer ist Bronze,
Silber, okay.
Die theoretische Prüfung
erfasst die Kenntnisse von Baderegeln
im Verhalten zur Selbstrettung, zum Beispiel
Verhalten bei Erschöpfung, Lösung von Kräften.
Keine Ahnung, ob ich diesen theoretischen
Prüfungsteil machen musste.
Damals schon Linux-Enjoyer,
genau, schon Pinguin. Okay, praktische
Prüfungsleistung. Sprung
kopfwärts vom Beckenrand und 20 Minuten
schwimmen. Ja, das hab ich.
Easy, ich konnte, ich konnte Stunden
schwimmen zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt.
Dieserzeit sind mindestens 400 Meter zurück.
Alter,
krass, oder?
Wie schafft man das nicht, 400 Meter,
wie schafft man das in unter, naja.
Äh, davon 300 Meter
in Bauch- oder Rückenlage
in einer erkennbaren Schwimmart und
400 Meter in der anderen Körperlage.
Okay. Zweimal circa
2 Meter tief tauchen von der Wasseroberfläche.
Ja, da kann ich
reinhören, das hab ich gemacht. 10 Meter
Strecken tauchen mit Abstoß. Ja, easy.
Sprung aus 3 Meter Höhe oder 2
verschiedene Sprünge aus 1 Meter Höhe. Ja, easy.
Nice. Ja, da war ich damals
ganz stolz drauf, dieses Ding auf der
Badehose zu haben.
Aber das Gold, Gold hab ich da
nie gemacht, da hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
Aber es war schon nice.
Ja, und jetzt hab ich überhaupt keinen Bock mehr
oben zu gehen.
Zumindest, ich wollte, ich wollte ja mal schnell.
Lass mich mal ganz kurz in meine App gucken.
Also ich konnte jetzt ja 3 Wochen nix
machen, ich bin einmal kurz ein bisschen
versucht zu joggen und einmal
30 Minuten Fahrrad gefahren.
3 Wochen lang hab ich quasi
nix gemacht, weil halt Schleimhautentzündung
im Magen und so, das war echt scheiße,
da sich mit groß bewegen.
Ich hab am Freitag wieder angefangen, langsame
Runde, dann gestern
2 Stunden Fahrrad fahren, heute
knapp ne Stunde.
50 Minuten, 50 Minuten.
Heute hab ich
7,55 Kilometer,
6 Minuten
34 pro Kilometer,
das ist so
recht zügig,
aber ne ganze
Ecke noch von dem weg,
was ich kann, wenn ich wirklich
all out renne, so dass ich
deadge bin danach.
So,
50, also 49,
31, so und jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt,
was die App
meint.
Okay, sogar plus Performance, guck, 3 Wochen
nix gemacht und meine App meint plus Performance.
Na dann,
Audersache zwar nicht so ganz, aber gut.
Nice.
Also ist anscheinend nicht so viel verloren gegangen
in 3 Wochen. Gut,
dann fangen wir mal mit dem normalen Programm an,
würde ich sagen. Programm? Alter, jetzt wäre das
super krass
geplant hier, schon im Vorfeld
irgendwie was überlegt. Ne,
wir gucken uns mal an, was auf Shithub trendet.
Moin.
Äh, sorry falls ich irgendjemand
übersehen habe hier.
Glaube ich aber nicht.
Ein Nachteil hat das, wenn man 3 Wochen
sich nicht richtig bewegt hat
und jetzt wieder anfängt, man hat
übertrieben Hunger. Ich hab jetzt Hunger.
Ich hab was gefuttert, bevor ich
losgerannt bin
und jetzt könnte ich schon wieder 2 Pizzas
fressen, ey.
Übelst Hunger, aber ich muss jetzt noch warten, so bis
12. Außerdem muss ich immer noch
ein bisschen auf meinen Magen achten,
dass es nicht wieder anfängt.
Ich sehe gerade,
vor 20 Minuten ist mir
der Stuttgart Champ gefolgt.
Der hat mal einen guten Namen, der Stuttgart
Champ. Bist du noch am Start?
Das könnte ein Fake Account
von mir sein, der
Stuttgart Champ. Ja, Arzi,
Dan, Dankeschön für eure Subs, falls ich nicht gesagt
hab. Der Splixxer hat auch letzten
Subscribed.
Sehe ich hier noch in der History. War ich
aber nicht da. Heute
keine Nudeln mit Lachs.
Äh, doch.
Tatsächlich, heute Nudeln mit Lachs,
allerdings mit Frankfurter
grüner Soße.
Grühsoß dabei.
Das ist immer gut
verträglich und ich will
nicht so viel fettigen Kram futtern, nachdem ich so
Magenprobleme hatte.
Was'n das? Das ist
eine
Ich weiß gar nicht, was die Base ist
davon. Letztendlich
sind das irgendwie
12 verschiedene Kräutersorten in
wahrscheinlich saure Sahne oder
so. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das macht.
So sieht das aus.
Also, so hier. Sieht jetzt hier vielleicht
nicht so appetitlich drauf aus, aber
das ist so eine Kräutersoße.
Das ist so hessische
hessische
Nationalspezialität.
So was geht
in Bayern gibt's Weißwürste dafür.
Und anderes Zeug. Das ist ja auch was hessisches.
So,
lass mal kurz gucken, was auf Shithub trendet.
Leute, ich muss
mal kurz noch was zu trinken holen. Ich bin in einer Minute
wieder da. Kurz mal
leer trinken. Ich renn mal kurz schnell runter und hol noch
einen Tee.
Ich bin wieder
am Start.
Ich hab gesehen, auf der Treppe
liegt noch
ein nicht geöffnetes
Amazon-Paket. Da muss ich
mal kurz reingucken, weil ich hab keine Ahnung,
was ich wieder bestellt hab.
Ähm, da muss ich mal kurz reingucken.
Wir machen jetzt quasi ein schnelles
Unboxing, ohne dass ihr's seht.
Das ist nicht sonderlich
satisfying, ich weiß. Aber ich muss
jetzt mal kurz reingucken. Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Ah, nice!
Da war ich ja schon drauf. Guckt mal.
Da wollte ich nämlich ein bisschen mit rum experimentieren.
Und zwar ist
das ein
Sonoff
Sick
Bidongel.
Allerdings die
diese Variante
mit dem neuen Chipsatz
Da wollte ich
die ganze Zeit nämlich schon mal ein bisschen damit rum
basteln. Der kann nämlich
mit der passenden Software
Sick Bidongel und Thread
über den gleichen Stick
machen.
Den kann man flashen mit Custom Firmware
Das ist keine Custom Firmware, das ist eigentlich Blödsinn.
Das ist glaube ich
Wobei, bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das
nicht vielleicht doch Custom Firmware
Zumindest gibt es da eine Firmware für.
Aber ich glaube, dass der Stick im Endeffekt
nur, sagen wir mal, als Antenne
fungiert und die Sick Bidongel
und Thread Logik basiert dann in
einer Software auf dem jeweiligen
Host System. Allerdings
kann man damit dann quasi, dadurch, dass
dieser Stick im Endeffekt nur als, sagen wir mal in Anführungszeichen,
Antenne fungiert,
kann man damit Sick Bidongel und Thread in einem
Gerät machen. Da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf,
weil ich gehe davon aus, dass ich über kurz
oder lang irgendwie Thread Geräte
bei mir in die Heimautomatisierung
einbauen werde und damit wollte ich
tatsächlich ein bisschen rumbasteln.
So, Stick, Sick Bidongel Stick.
Was haben wir da
sonst noch hier Schönes?
Was ist denn das?
Du bist zu doof, den zu flashen.
Ja dann, let's go.
Gut, dass du es sagst.
Äh
Sonoff
E-Dongel flashen. Ich muss das Ding
auch flashen.
Können wir das mal zusammen ausprobieren
im Stream. So und dann habe ich hier noch ein paar
Sachen, die sehen ehrlich gesagt relativ unspektakulär
aus. Ein,
zwei Packages.
Zwei Packages.
Oh, das ist jetzt
eigentlich nicht der Rede. CX4XH
5 Pin
Connectors. Hier
sowas. Bloß auf beiden Seiten schon
fertig.
Sowas hier.
Ein Packages mit
ich glaube 10
5 Pins und
ein Package mit
jeweils 2 2 Pin, 2 3 Pin
2 4 Pin, 2 5 Pin
2 6 Pin. Weil diese
Dinger braucht man immer mal wieder. Diese Kabel.
Und als letztes habe ich noch
Was ist das? Ich glaube das habe ich
für meinen Bastel, Bastelkrams
hier.
Ah, schon fertig
vorkonfektionierte Breadboard
Steckkabel.
Ja, das habe ich mir wahrscheinlich mal
auf gut Glück bestellt.
Weil ich die anderen nicht mehr gefunden habe.
Ja,
das ist jetzt nicht
so
Sowas hier ist das.
Breadboard Kabel
Set.
Sowas hier in der Richtung, genau.
Bloß nicht das.
Eher, es sieht
eher so aus. Schadet
nix, da mal ein paar auf Lager zu
haben. Die werde ich einfach in meine Bastel
Kiste ist es nicht.
Schublade.
Und gut ist.
Ich habe extra so zwei Schränke
mit durchsichtigen
Schubladen für den ganzen Bastelkram.
Dass ich von draußen reingucken kann.
Und ich habe eine Kiste, da ist dieser ganze
Elektronikkram für Bastel, also
nicht alles, da sind so Sachen wie Widerstände
drin oder Pinheader oder
solche Kabel und so, dass man es findet.
Und den ganzen Sensorkram
den habe ich in so einem ganz kleinen
Sortierschrank
von ich glaube Stanley
Schrank oder so.
Weiß nicht genau.
Sowas hier, ja genau, sowas hier.
Sowas hier oben.
Das ist für Sensoren
ist das super. Da habe ich einen mit
Ultraschallsensoren drin, einen mit
Temperatursensoren, da findet man
den Kram wieder. Ist bei mir nicht wirklich ordentlich.
Aber ich suche einfach immer viel
zu lang diesen ganzen Kram, deswegen
hab ich das mal ein bisschen
ordentlich gemacht. Okay.
Gut, das war in meiner Amazon, in meinem
Amazon Package drin. Alles klar.
Exzellent.
Da können wir Github Trends uns angucken.
Arrowchild, danke für den
Sub. So, also was
trendet denn diese Woche auf Github?
Lass uns mal gucken.
AI, was sonst?
Ah.
Facebook
Lama. So, Meta.
Meta.
Was macht eigentlich das Metaverse
so?
Außer keine Beine haben.
Oh,
AI, AI.
AI.
AI. AI. AI.
AI. AI.
Ah.
Emulator für,
ja,
Emulator für iOS, den man
über Custom App Stores, wobei
gibt es den mittlerweile auch im offiziellen App Store?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Über Custom App Stores installieren kann.
Man streng genommen
ist es ja nicht illegal, einen Emulator anzubieten.
Es ist illegal, sich
die ROMs kopiergeschützt
zu besorgen.
Also streng genommen ist ja der
Hersteller des
Emulators fein raus,
wenn er nicht
irgendwelche strittigen
Sachen drin hat, so wie
Yuzu, hier sind die, gell?
Die sicherlich an der Weite
schon wieder back sind.
Okay, also
hoffentlich müsste ich vielleicht
auch mal ausprobieren.
Das Metaverse sucht noch seine Existenzberechtigung.
Ja, die habe ich noch nie verstanden.
VR Chat, wenn man auf sowas, das verstehe ich
halt nicht, wenn man auf sowas steht,
ja, dann ist VR Chat
einfach das Beste, was es gibt.
Ich meine, die meisten Leute haben
von VR Chat, glaube ich, nur
was auch immer, Uganda Knuckles mitbekommen.
Falls sich da noch irgendjemand
dran erinnert. Aber,
also, wenn jemand so, wenn jemand
sowas mag, dann ist er einfach VR.
Warum sollte der irgendwas mit, warum sollte
der irgendwas mit
Metaverse von Facebook machen?
Wobei Facebook ja auch eher
auf die Business-Sache abzielt,
ja? Und da ist VR Chat
halt nicht unbedingt zu gebrauchen für.
Ich glaube, niemand
möchte ein seriöses
sagen wir mal
irgendwie
irgendeine Besprechung in VR Chat
abhalten. Wir haben
alle nur Sicherheitskopien von unseren eigenen
Sachen, selbstverständlich.
Die ganzen Sachen, die es im
Internet zum Download gibt, die sind
ja eigentlich da gar nicht zum Download. Das sind einfach
nur Sicherheitskopien, dass, falls das Original mal
kaputt geht, man sich das wieder
selbst recovern kann.
War damals auch schon
so. Es waren immer nur Sicherheitskopien.
Streng genommen.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
AI? Äh,
keine Ahnung. AI?
AI? AI?
Zeug? China-Chinesen-Kram?
AI?
Alter.
AI? Ey, also diese
Woche ist, glaube ich, die schlechteste Woche ever
bei Github-Trends.
Das sind ja im Endeffekt
95% Lama-
und AI-Kram gewesen.
Meine Güte, das ist ja
für'n Arsch. Gucken wir mal, was
in der .NET-Welt so trendet.
Okay.
Nichts Spannendes.
Das hat sich nicht gelohnt, diese Woche da
reinzugucken.
Ähm, so eine Fotoverwaltung, oder?
Wenn ich den Namen
sehe...
Ja, bin ich. Warum?
Also, ich benutze die eigentlich so gut wie nicht
mehr. Ich hab da noch ein Account.
Ich hab da noch...
Ich hab da noch ne... Ich hab da halt noch ein Account.
Was
ganz nice ist für temporäre
Kreditkarten, die man halt
einmalig braucht.
Ich hab grad versucht, die App zu öffnen.
Es hat mich ausgelockt.
Ich werd mich da wahrscheinlich nie wieder einloggen. Keine Ahnung.
Also, meine Stonks
hab ich allerdings bei Scalable.
Und da muss ich
grad mal reingucken, was die Stonks so machen.
Ja.
Geht so.
Warum fragst du?
Also, ich war da ja nie großartig.
Ich war da immer nur für temporäre Kreditkarten,
wenn man halt nicht seine
jahrelang gültigen Kreditkarten bei irgendeinem China-Chinesen-Shop
oder so hinterlegen will.
Repaid.
Jaja, ist es. Wie gesagt, ich verdiene ja
mein Geld auch zum größten Teil aktuell mit
Crypto-Blockchain-Sachen.
Nicht als Crypto-Bro
oder so, ne, wo ich auf Twitter die neuesten
Shitcoins promote, sondern
ich arbeite bei einer Versicherung in Frankfurt
und dort ist Blockchain-Technologie
und Crypto-Assets,
wie man es so schön nennt,
mittlerweile auch ein Thema. Was aber auch
bedeutet, wenn es dort mittlerweile ein Thema ist,
dass das, was wir machen, wahrscheinlich schon wieder
hoffnungslos
nicht mehr im Trend ist.
Weil du kannst auf eine Sache, eine Sache
sicher sein, wenn die großen
Frankfurter Versicherungen und Banken
anfangen mit irgendeinem Thema, dann ist
das meistens schon wieder bei den coolen
Leuten out.
So, you're done?
GitHub war nichts
Spannendes diesmal drinnen.
Nein, nein, das Goat hier ist gar nichts on.
Lass mal schauen, was haben wir denn hier
Schönes?
Ich weiß nicht warum, aber irgendwie muss ich
das jetzt angucken.
Wie sie mit dem Poppes wackelt, das hat Chico auch
immer gemacht, wenn sie irgendwas fangen wollte.
Und die hier auch.
Und hopp.
Und hat sie es erwischt?
Nein, hat sie nicht erwischt.
Ja, das machen sie manchmal, wenn sie
super aufgeregt sind.
Zum Beispiel,
wo Katzen sowas super, also wo die
komplett ausflippen können,
nicht alle, aber die
meine Vorletzte ist
da immer komplett ausgeflippt.
Die hier.
Wenn die Vögel
durchs Fenster gesehen hat
und ist nicht rausgekommen.
Wenn die Vögel quasi, wenn die in der Küche
am Fenster gesessen hat und im Hof waren Vögel
und die wollte raus, aber die Tür war
zu und was auch immer, da ist die voll aus,
da ist die Firma aus, da saß die immer da und hat
genau sowas gemacht. Genau solche Geräusche.
Ah, ich will dahin, ich will dahin, ich will dahin,
ich kann nicht, ich will dahin.
Ja.
Oder wenn irgendwas im Hof rumkrabbelt
und sie kann grad nicht. Oh.
Was machst du hier auf meinem Rasen, Alter?
Piss dich. Piss dich, Alter.
Ja.
Stärkste Katze überhaupt, muss man natürlich
immer demonstrieren. Man sollte
bei sowas nicht auf die blöde
Idee kommen.
Hier, Leute. Man sollte
hier nicht versuchen, an den Bauch zu fassen.
Dann hast du die Krallen in der Hand.
Jetzt, ein dummes Ding kann man gar nicht richtig fangen.
Jetzt erstmal schlafen
ne Runde, das war jetzt viel zu anstrengend, ja.
Ich auch so. Meine
hat immer,
wenn die sich so gejuckt hat,
und du hast sie dann mitgekratzt,
so an der Seite, wenn du gesagt hast, aha, da scheint's
zu jucken,
dann hast du sie, da hat sie sich vor dich gestellt
und du musstest sie kratzen, so,
am Kopf, und da hat die,
wenn du sie gekratzt hast am Kopf,
hat die mit ihrem Bein immer so mitgemacht, so.
Die konnte das irgendwie im Kopf nicht
trennen, mit
es juckt mich, ich werde
gekratzt, aber
ich bin's nicht selbst. Die hat dann immer
mit ihrem Bein mitgeschwungen, wenn du sie am Kopf
gekratzt hast. Sie muss
sie sich aber immer zusammenreißen, weil sie
einer sonst die Hand gekratzt hätte, wenn sie das Bein
wirklich am Kopf gemacht hätte. Die hast du dann quasi
die hast du dann quasi am Kopf
gekratzt, und die hat permanent, während du sie
am Kopf gekratzt hast, mit ihrem Bein
so
immer versucht mitzukratzen, aber
ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht, ich muss mich
mitkratzen. Das hat sie
irgendwie überfordert.
Dieses
Android Smartphone kann
man mit einem Desktop-PC ersetzen. Ja,
G-Bait, Alter, G-Bait.
Kann es nicht,
weil man einen Desktop-PC hat,
nicht nur um einen großen Bildschirm zu haben,
sondern halt auch, um damit Desktop-Sachen
zu machen, ne. Ordentliche Maus-Tastatur-
Bedienung mit der passenden Software
dafür, die auf Maus- und Tastatur-Bedienung
ausgelegt ist.
Quick look at my Homelab,
da bin ich immer dabei. Jeff,
zeig uns dein Homelab.
Sowas find ich immer
spannend.
Let's go take a look at the
Homelab.
Let's go downstairs.
The ground level is right about here.
So when we get down the stairs, we'll be
underground.
Alter, er ist ja schon am Schnaufen beim Loslaufen.
So wie ich früher auch.
This door here goes to the secret lab.
Früher war ich auch schon immer am Schnaufen
beim Treppelaufen. Mittlerweile,
mittlerweile geht es eigentlich.
Und was ich gemerkt
habe ist, also ich war früher auch der richtige
Kekona, was das angeht.
Was ich auch gemerkt habe ist,
seitdem ich regelmäßig Fahrrad fahren gehe,
wenn ich jetzt die Treppe schnell
hochlaufe,
es brennt nicht mehr
in den Oberschenkeln so schnell.
Wenn ich jetzt vom ersten in fünften Stock
laufe oder so, volle Pulle, dann immer noch.
Aber nicht mal bei normalen Treppen,
wo man mal schnell hochläuft,
merke ich dann gar nicht mehr danach
in den Oberschenkeln. Merke ich wird ein bisschen
warm, aber das war's. Hast du mittlerweile
wieder ein neues Bike? Ja, habe ich.
Ausrufezeichen, wir machen das auch.
Fahrrad, wenn man das jetzt richtig schreibt.
Fahrrad, Omega-Keckel,
Max-Fahrrad.
Blöde Idee auf die Rose-Webseite
zu verlinken.
Man sieht es hier oben in der URL noch, was es
für eins ist. Wenn man danach sucht,
findet man es wahrscheinlich.
Google Cash
gibt es nicht mehr, oder?
Wisst ihr, das finde ich
so scheiße.
So richtig
scheiße. Anders kann ich sagen,
dass Google den Cash abgeschaltet hat.
Ich fand
legit den,
das ist das falsche, aber
ich fand legit den Google Cash
eines der besten
Features von Google überhaupt.
Wir gucken mal, ob
Internet Archive
sowas hat.
Wait a minute.
Hier.
Dann vielleicht auch das da weg.
Hier, nice.
Haben wir einmal archiviert, sehr gut.
Excellent.
Vielleicht können wir den Link anpassen.
High IQ
Chatkes
Mods
Ja, das habe ich am Start
hier. Habe ich nicht
bezahlt.
Das war günstiger.
Hat glaube ich nur 2.300 Euro
gekostet.
Weil das nicht
so das aller aktuellste Modell mehr ist.
Allerdings
hat Shimano noch keine neue
elektronische Schaltung vorgestellt
mit 1x12 für Gravel Bikes.
Das kommt irgendwann im Sommer.
Deswegen.
Ich habe noch die alte 2x11
nicht
1x12 oder 2x12.
Und ich habe das Fahrrad aber auch schon
selbst auseinander genommen und habe
hier hinten eine größere Kassette reingemacht.
Hier hinten habe ich jetzt 40.
1140 und nicht
oder so, was da normal ist.
Was sehr nice ist,
kommen wir jetzt einfach in den Berg hoch.
Zumindest das ist das Fahrrad, was ich
aktuell habe.
Die Seite muss ich mal bookmarken.
Ach ja, und übrigens war als Update
die Versicherung von
dem Unfall letztes Jahr.
Mein Fahrrad ist ja Schrott.
Ich hatte einen Unfall letztes Jahr mit meinem Fahrrad.
Und da hat mich eine
auf dem Fahrradweg
auf der Vorfahrt
von mir von der Seite umgefahren.
Also ich hatte
Vorfahrt, die hatte ein Schild Vorfahrt achten.
Hat mich trotzdem von der Seite umgefahren.
Und das Fahrrad ist kaputt.
Gutachter sagt Totalschaden.
Restwert 80 Euro oder sowas.
Und die Versicherung hat das auch anerkannt.
Hat keinen Einspruch, aber die haben bis jetzt immer noch nicht
alles bezahlt. Und es wird tagtäglich
teurer für die.
Ausfall plus Anwaltskosten werden bei jedem Brief,
den er da hinschreibt, mehr.
Die haben mittlerweile knapp die Hälfte bezahlt,
aber den Rest immer noch nicht.
Mittlerweile ist da so viel Geld zusammen,
kommt da so viel Geld zusammen,
dass das neue Fahrrad
fast das doppelte
oder so ist.
Quasi ein Fahrrad umsonst.
Richtig dumm.
Ich mein, vor allem
mich juckt es nicht.
Der Anwalt kümmert sich drum, ich hab überhaupt
bekommst du das dann
oder der Anwalt?
Der Anwalt bekommt sein Geld
davon.
Ich bekomme aber auch mehr, weil
ich hab ja quasi dadurch einen Ausfall.
Also aktuell ist es das
doppelte ungefähr nur wegen dem Gutachter
und den Anwaltskosten, der Rest noch nicht.
Also das kriege ich nicht alles.
Aber insgesamt,
wenn die sich noch ein bisschen Zeit
lassen, wer weiß.
Vielleicht hat sich das neue Fahrrad dann auch bezahlt.
Ja.
Ist eigentlich schon affig, wenn du das überlegst.
Die hat mich letztes Jahr irgendwann im November oder so
Anfang November umgefahren.
Und es ist jetzt
Mai.
Und die haben immer noch nicht bezahlt.
Über ein halbes Jahr. Ist halt voll von Arsch.
Wenn das mal jemand bräuchte, das wäre da wirklich
drauf angewiesen. Es wäre vielleicht was Wichtigeres
als ein Fahrrad.
Der hätte nicht genug Kohle mal auf der hohen Kante sich
ein neues zu kaufen.
Bist halt ganz schön
am Arsch.
Ich verstehe auch gar nicht, warum das erlaubt
ist, über ein halbes Jahr,
wenn es unstrittig ist,
das hinzuziehen.
Ja, aber die sind dumm, das kostet die nur mehr.
Die sind richtig dumm.
Nee, gar nicht.
Sie stimmen unseren Forderungen zu
und die haben auch schon teilweise überwiesen.
Erst haben sie sich rausgeredet mit
Ja, sie wollen keine Mehrwertsteuer bezahlen.
Warum auch immer, obwohl man ganz klar
in der Rechnung gesehen hat, dass ich das als Privatperson gekauft habe.
Dann doch. Dann haben sie da wieder was vergessen.
Ey, oder was heißt vergessen?
Vergessen haben sie sich absichtlich nicht mitbezahlt.
Ich weiß nicht, warum die so blöd sind.
Mir ist es vollkommen egal.
Ich habe mir ein neues Fahrrad gekauft mittlerweile.
Der Anwalt macht das. Ich habe da keine Aufwände mit.
Ich kriege im Endeffekt nur mehr Geld.
Und die verlieren Kohle.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum die da so lange für brauchen.
Der Anwalt freut sich,
weil er für jeden Brief und alles gut bezahlt wird.
Der Anwalt freut sich, weil er für jeden Brief und alles gut bezahlt wird.
Die haben nur Nachteile dadurch.
Ich weiß nicht, warum die so lahm sind.
Die sind so dumm.
Und ich bin so froh, dass ich das dem Anwalt gegeben habe.
Ich habe mir ja am Anfang gedacht, ey, die Sache ist so klar.
Und auch Fotos und allem so klar,
da brauchst du keinen Anwalt.
Aber schon einen Tag nach meinem Unfall
habe ich mir das mal überlegt und habe mir gedacht,
doch,
doch, du lässt das ein Anwalt machen.
Du hast keinen Bock, dich mit denen rumzustreiten.
Also direkt nächste Woche zum Anwalt.
Nö.
Anwalt hier bei mir um die Ecke.
Ich meine, ich hatte ein bisschen Stress damit,
dass ich zu einem Gutachter rennen musste.
Was die gegnerische Versicherung sicherlich auch gemacht hätte.
Aber wer weiß, wie objektiv dann denen ihr Gutachter ist.
Wenn so ein Gutachter...
Das hat auch irgendwie geknackt.
Knapp 1000 Euro oder so gekostet.
Fucking Gutachten.
Aber gut, soll er ruhig abrechnen.
Er hat das ja auch super ausführlich gemacht.
Ich muss es eh nicht bezahlen.
Also es ist echt komplett witzlos.
Ich finde es halt nur affig,
dass es überhaupt erlaubt ist,
das so lange rauszuzögern.
Mir ist es jetzt persönlich wurscht.
Für mich ist es sogar noch gut,
umso länger die brauchen.
Aber es mag ja durchaus Leute geben,
die so viel weniger riskieren als ein Fahrrad.
Ja und das sind Kleinbeträge für die.
Was juckt die denn im Endeffekt?
Na mittlerweile sind wir
glaube ich bei 5000 oder so.
Aber was juckt die das überhaupt?
Die können froh sein, dass ich nicht noch
die Fußballtaktik gemacht habe
und mich hingeschmissen habe.
Mein Bein!
Ich bin so schwer verletzt,
dass ich da irgendwie noch
drei Wochen Verdienstausfall
und whatever.
Ich war noch nicht mal krank,
deswegen.
Die können doch nicht froh sein.
Die hätten noch viel mehr bezahlen müssen
im Zweifelsfall.
Wenn wirklich was gewesen wäre.
Nein, nein.
Kein Schmerzensgeld und nichts
habe ich auch nicht vor.
Aber wenn es ein bisschen anders
ausgegangen wäre,
hätte das durchaus sein können.
Oder einer, sagen wir mal,
der es vielleicht darauf anlegt.
Ganz ehrlich,
die hätten am meisten Geld mitgespart.
Hätten die mich montags angerufen,
hätten sie gesagt, Herr Max,
Geld ist schon auf dem Weg.
Passt alles.
Und dann wäre ich wahrscheinlich
noch nicht mal zum Anwalt.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Ich muss auch sagen,
AI-Code-Sachen...
Ich bin noch nicht komplett überzeugt.
Ich benutze das manchmal,
so Sachen wie Ansible-Files checken
Es liegt aber auch daran,
dass ich ganz am Anfang mal
ein paar Sachen mit Chat-GPT probiert habe.
Und...
Das hat so einen Scheiß dazu
halluziniert.
Methoden, die es nicht gibt.
Und als ich Chat-GPT gesagt habe,
das gibt es nicht, hat es mir eine
Windows-Forms-Anwendung gebaut,
obwohl ich eigentlich eine Konsolenanwendung wollte.
Ja, haben wir.
Wäre es sicherlich nicht wert gewesen.
Chat, hattet ihr schon mal was gebrochen?
Ich noch nie.
Ich hatte noch nie irgendwas...
Ich überlege gerade nicht, dass ich jetzt Scheiße erzähle,
ob nicht vielleicht irgendwas Kleines war,
wo ich gerade nicht dran denke.
Zumindest nichts Großes.
Keine Arme, Beine und so.
Ich hatte mal vor kurzem
die blöde Vermutung,
ich habe mir die Nase gebrochen.
Habe ich aber glücklicherweise doch nicht.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich gemacht habe,
aber ich habe im Flur was gebastelt.
Und bin beim Aufstehen...
Also...
Das muss man erstmal schaffen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das geht.
Hier ist das...
Hier geht so mein Geländer.
Hier geht so mein Geländer lang.
Hier geht die Treppe runter.
Kann man sich, glaube ich, ganz gut vorstellen.
Und ich muss
irgendwo hier was gemacht haben.
Ich habe keine Ahnung was.
Zumindest habe ich mich
gedreht.
Ich habe hier irgendwas gemacht
und habe mich so gedreht.
Und meine Nase,
also wenn das hier meine Nase ist,
so...
Big nose.
Habe ich die quasi
aus der Drehbewegung
hier drangehauen
gegen das Geländer.
Oh, da bin ich umgekippt.
Das war so richtig wie
einmal voll in die Fresse geschlagen.
Boah.
Und da habe ich gedacht, fuck, Alter.
Nicht Nase gebrochen.
Aber war zum Glück nix.
Da hatte ich ein bisschen
Panik erstmal.
Die drehen ja auch übelst die Augen
und alles.
War zum Glück nix.
Ich habe mir noch nie was gebrochen.
Ich habe es auch nicht vor,
nachzuholen.
Und das, obwohl, wie ich klein war.
Ich bin Bäume geklettert.
Ich habe allen möglichen gefährlichen Kram gemacht
früher.
Aber nie was passiert.
Immer gut ausgegangen.
Schmerzhafter als Brüche, ich glaube.
Das kommt ganz entscheidend auf den Bruch an
und auf die Prellung.
Ja, ich weiß, das habe ich auch schon gehört,
aber das kommt bestimmt
immer auf den Einzelfall an.
Moin.
Gut.
Ah ja, wir wollten uns ja das Homelab von dem Typ angucken.
Hast du schon die diesjährige Abschlussprüfung
gemacht?
Aber ich darf die wie immer nicht im Stream zeigen,
weil die Copyright gekopyrightet ist.
Wenn jetzt jemand zufällig eine Frage
in den Chat postet,
da kann ich natürlich nix dagegen machen.
Man kann die Frage ja ein bisschen verändern,
dass es nicht eins zu eins die Frage ist.
So.
Dann schauen wir uns doch mal das Homelab
von Jeff an.
Radiation...
Danger Laser...
Warum?
Da ist wahrscheinlich weder Laser noch Radiation
Area drin.
Da findet das einfach, glaube ich, keck weight.
Das...
Warning, no stupid people...
Werden das
auch jemand, der Windows sagt?
Okay, Windows sagen die Leute nur in
Deutsch. Wie sagen denn die Amis
dazu eigentlich?
Wenn die Windows falsch aussprechen
wollen, absichtlich.
Also...
Und wisst ihr was Windows...
Okay. Wisst ihr was besonders
gut ist?
Mini-Weich-Window, Alter.
Das ist so krasser Boomer-Humor,
da cringet sich mir immer alles.
Fühlst du dich manchmal einsam?
Ne, ich hab doch den Twitch-Chat.
Und jetzt mal auf etwas realistischere
Note. Ich meine, wir kennen uns ja nicht
persönlich. Ihr mich schon, ich euch nicht so.
Wirklich. Also...
Ich glaube, es gibt Momente,
da hat jeder mal sowas, woraus ich denke,
ey...
Wär nice, wenn man da...
Aber hält sich in Grenzen. Bei mir,
liegt's aber auch mit daran,
dass mir die meisten Leute, also
die meisten anderen Menschen, so extrem auf den
Sack gehen. Ich bin froh, dass ich
die paar Leute kenne, die ich kenne und ich
mich mit denen gut verstehe, mit denen ich mich gut verstehe.
Aber mehr bräuchte ich nicht.
Ganz ehrlich.
Die meisten Leute gehen mir einfach nur
auf den Sack. Und das oftmals durch pure
Anwesenheit. Teil 2
der Abschlussprüfung war fast 100% Netzwerktechnik.
Das kann gut oder
schlecht sein, je nachdem. Wenn die
V6 tiefgreifende Sachen wissen,
wäre ich aufgeschmissen.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal an.
Das... das Homelab von Jeff.
Boah, der hat aber... der hat aber einen
riesen Keller, Jeff, oder?
Ganz schön am Schnaufen, der Jeff.
Wait a minute, der hat eine... der hat eine
USV für sein komplettes Haus?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Weil, wenn das hier alles die
USV ist, Alter...
Nee, das sind nicht alles die...
Da steht da einfach nur... Doch!
Doch! Das ist wirklich eine
fette USV fürs ganze Haus!
Ist normal in den USA.
Macht man das so?
Ja gut, die haben auch öfters mal Stromausfälle.
...
Er hat einfach mal ein paar Ersatzswitche.
Wir haben mal so 5, 48 Port Ersatzswitche, kann man da schon mal haben.
Ah, Grafana.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Mal erstmal kurz zurückspulen, bis die Kamera...
Wir kennen es nicht.
Outside Temperature, Server Room Temperature, Humidity, Rack.
87 Millisekunden, für was?
Ah, hier kann man es gut erkennen.
Ping 2, was?
Sponge, und hier ist der Ping 7,1.
0,41 Inches, aber schon ganz schön klein.
Für was?
Aber Inch, Inch.
Also die Cringe-Einheit schlechthin.
Ist aber bestimmt cool, da durchzulaufen und auf einen Blick zu sehen.
Okay, passt alles.
Wind Speed?
Dust Speed?
Was ist denn der Unterschied?
Ping to Google, 19 Millisekunden.
Für meinen Geschmack ist es ein bisschen wasted,
weil man könnte auf dem Panel noch deutlich mehr anzeigen,
aber nachdem es kein Touchscreen ist, hält es sich natürlich in Grenzen,
die Möglichkeiten, die man hat, vielleicht irgendwie schnell was zu steuern.
Temperature, Temperature outside, Server Room Temperature,
some other things, some Ping Times to different services,
a few weather-related things.
And so this kiosk will also between this...
Letztendlich ist es aber egal, ob es für uns gut ist.
Es muss für ihn passen.
Das sage ich ja bei jeglicher Heimatomatisierung oder Bastellei daheim immer.
Das muss individuell passen zu dem, was man vorhat.
Man kann sich inspirieren lassen von dem, was andere Leute gemacht haben.
Aber man sollte sich da nicht so viel aufschwätzen oder reinreden lassen,
weil es muss eben persönlich zu dem passen, was man machen will.
Und wenn man bei Bastelprojekten nicht weiterkommt,
dann wirst du ja immer schön ins Mikrocontroller-Forum gehen.
Da wird einem geholfen.
mikrocontroller.net, bestes Forum überhaupt.
Das kannst du auch noch machen, wenn Strom billig ist.
Beton? Was ist da los? Das ist kein Holz!
Das ist kein richtiges Kokona Home.
Wir hören es wirklich nicht, bis sie die Tür rawend geöffnet haben.
Boah!
Da sind wir ja.
Neiße Beleuchtung
Das ist zwar komplett Overkill dafür
Sehr schön.
Ohne Mist.
Das ist ein wirklich... Wie geleckt.
Also echt nice.
Zwar komplett Overkill wahrscheinlich
und übertriebenび
aber es sieht Rechenzentrumiga aus
als viele rechte Rechenzentren.
Alter, was hat er da wieder drin, Mann?
Guck mal, der hat den gleichen Schrank wie ich.
Zum Sortieren von Elektronik-Kleinkram.
Ja, das Lab sieht besser aus wie das Wohnzimmer, ja, richtig.
Es ist enorm wichtig, dass man LED-Strips in seinem Rack drin hat.
Das ist allein mal der Performance-Boost, Leute.
Guck mal, was ist denn das alte HP-Zeug, oder?
Von den Farben her, oder Dell.
Ich bring das immer durcheinander.
Also das da oben ist Dell.
HP war früher auch so rötlich, so DL380 und sowas.
Da, QX, dankeschön.
Ja, mittlerweile sind die Dinger grün,
aber früher waren die genau sowas hier.
Hier, so dieses, dieses, dieses, hier, da, genau.
So sahen die Dinger früher aus, ja.
Machen wir mal Gen 5 oder so, machen wir mal was Altes.
Ja, genau.
Ja, HP war früher so, oder Gen 6.
HP war früher so dunkel, dunkelrot-braun, ja.
Also von der Farbe her sieht das schon nach...
Und gerade diese Dinger, weiß ich nicht, mal gucken, was es ist.
Die alten IBM-Dinger hat man immer gut erkannt.
Und was ich bis heute nicht verstanden habe,
ist bei den alten IBM-Dingern,
da war immer so eine Metallkugel vorne,
im Gehäuse, so eine kleine.
Und ich habe bis heute nicht gecheckt,
wofür die da war.
Ah, man sieht es jetzt nicht.
Bin ich jetzt...
Die hatten oftmals früher hier vorne,
in diesem Gitter,
steckte so eine Metallkugel drin.
Und ich habe bis heute nicht gecheckt, wofür...
Das war einfach, glaube ich,
einfach für die Optik, oder?
Ja.
Oder Proxmox-Cluster.
Was haben die wieder daheim laufen, Alter?
Und guck mal, wie viel Storage, Mann.
Alles SSDs.
Also ich gebe zu, es ist super nice,
sowas zu haben.
Ja, also der haben-Faktor.
Aber was machst du denn damit?
Ich meine, selbst, wie heißt,
der Typ, ähm,
der 5-Kubernetes-Cluster-Daheim-Typ,
ähm, wo wir manchmal gucken.
Selbst der hat ja
da drauf nix laufen.
Der hat Sachen, um sein Zeug
zu verwalten, darauf laufen und
und ein Dashboard oder so.
Ja, ja, genau, genau, Tech und Tim.
Tech und Tim.
Der hat das ja auch alles super hübsch gemacht und
aber im Endeffekt hat er auch nur
Management, um Management
zu betreiben.
Ich frag mich echt, was
der da alles drauf laufen hat, hier.
Was hat er da alles drauf laufen, Alter?
Okay, Dual Xeon heißt,
das ist irgendwas von
Ebay?
Die Dinger sehen auch schon ein bisschen älter aus.
Oder meint er, das ist ein aktueller Xeon,
davon hat er zwei Stück on board? Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Nur ein halbes Terabyte RAM.
Da geht aber noch was.
Schön, schön mit den Kabeln
hat er das gemacht, find ich nice, dass er das ja auch
in Packung gekauft hat, mit kurzen.
Ja, Glasfaserkabel am Start.
Da hinten hat er noch mal
einstehen.
Ja.
Also ohne Scheiß, das ist Rechenzentrumiger
als viele Rechenzentren.
Hat sogar eine KVM,
wo er sich... Moment, Moment, wie viele
Maschinen?
32 Maschinen?
32?
Alter!
Wow!
Oh, shit!
Monitoring Alert
von der Arbeit.
Habt ihr das gerade gehört im Hintergrund?
Problem, kritisch.
Ei, ei, ei.
Jetzt geht's aber los hier.
Alarm!
Hört er gar nicht mehr auf, ey.
Guck mal kurz rein.
Ah, okay, der übliche
Service, der immer Probleme hat.
MSSQL
Connection Failed.
Da bin ich raus, Leute.
Da bin ich raus.
Alter, es hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Jetzt werde ich noch angerufen.
Ich muss da mal kurz drangehen.
Ja, okay.
Ich wurde nicht angerufen.
Das war nur das Monitoring-System,
das gedacht hat, das hat mich nicht erreicht.
Ja, nee, MSSQL ist nix für mich.
Das ignoriere ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ich bin eh nicht im Einsatz.
Insofern
kann ich es doppelt ignorieren.
Also ich habe keine Rufbereitschaft
oder so am Wochenende.
Ich habe nur hier nebenbei mir das Handy liegen gehabt.
Deswegen habe ich mal drauf geguckt gerade.
MSSQL Server Failed.
Ja, gut, nice.
Da bin ich ja zum Glück raus.
Da habe ich nichts mit zu tun.
Okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Alter, 32 Maschinen.
Leaked, ja.
Ja.
Ah!
Ah, so sieht das bei mir auch aus.
Da hat er recht.
Das Problem ist, dass 10 Gig SFP Plus Module viel zu teuer sind.
Ja, bei mir sind da andere Sachen drin.
Aber genau dieses Regal habe ich auch für sowas hier.
Das ist das, was ich euch vorhin gezeigt habe.
Oder mehr oder weniger dieses Regal.
Ich habe nicht so geschönte, geriffelte Dinger da oben.
Ich habe da meine ganzen Elektronik-Sensoren und sowas drin liegen.
Ah, Rack hier hat ein paar Haus-Wire-Sensoren drin.
Also 10 Gig Core-Switch.
All these fibers go over to the rack over there.
Some of the single-wood fibers go to two other...
Sag mal, sehe ich das richtig, dass das Hälfte von dem Zeug, was er da hat, ist Netzwerk-Equipment?
Was ist denn da alles angeschlossen und was machen die da eigentlich?
Wo bekommt man dieses Regal her bei Amazon?
Ja, ich habe das vorhin gezeigt.
Ist das der Wendler?
Nee, oder?
Nee, nee, nee.
Was macht der Wendler eigentlich?
Gibt es den noch?
Ja.
So sehr interessiert es mich auch nicht.
Es ist mir so zu sagen...
Egal.
Was der macht.
Äh, Schrank oder Regal.
Hier.
Was ist das Ding?
Also ich habe den unteren und den oberen Teil allerdings in zwei unterschiedlichen Schränken.
Das ist sehr praktisch zum Sortieren von Kleinkram.
Besser nicht nach...
Nee, nee, ich habe noch nicht nachgeguckt.
So sehr interessiert es mich nicht.
Was hat der für krasses Equipment im Haus verteilt mit dem ganzen Netzwerkzeug?
Ich meine, ganz ehrlich...
Oh, Mist.
Ich denke mir ja schon immer...
Ich denke mir ja schon immer, ich bin etwas übertrieben unterwegs hier mit meinem Server-Technik.
Da sieht es schon ein bisschen besser aus als...
Ja.
Bestes Kabelmanagement, by the way.
Ich dachte schon, ich bin da irgendwie ein bisschen...
Was gibt es denn hier sonst noch Schönes?
Also ganz hier unten...
Bisschen übertrieben unterwegs im Vergleich zu den meisten Leuten, ja?
Aber das ist ja echt mal komplett next level.
... zwei Maschinen in hier.
Und ein paar der Signalblut-Fiber gehen zu zwei anderen Klassik, die oben sind.
PFSense Beste, äh nee nee, Autosense Beste, nicht PFSense Beste, Keck Wait Alter was da
los.
Aber man muss echt sagen, ich mein vorne sieht stylischer aus als hinten, also für
das, wenn er das alles selbst gemacht hat.
Da ist sehr viel Arbeit reingeflossen und ich finde auch, dass er das sehr schick gemacht
hat.
Was der Strom bei denen kostet, ja das würde ich auch gerne wissen.
Bist du dir sicher, dass das nur ein Netzteil ist?
Ich meine nur weil es ein Stecker ist, heißt es nicht, dass es nur ein Netzteil ist.
Meistens zwar schon, aber je nachdem was es ist nicht unbedingt.
Das könnte durchaus hier Dual Netzteil oder so sein, keine Ahnung.
Ich seh das gar nicht, wo ist denn das Netzteil?
Hier irgendwo, nee das ist Dual Netzteil hier.
Guck, ein Netzteil, zwei Netzteile.
Ich würd sagen, das ist Dual Netzteil.
Hat sogar gesagt zwei, siehste.
Vor allem was das auch gekostet hat, alles ey.
Prima, schöne Stromkabel.
Ja.
Das sind die Hauptpartien davon.
Da ist eine kleine Tür da, wo die Oompa Loompas leben, so wie wir sie alleine haben.
Und äh das ist es.
Das zeigt euch mein äh Home Lab.
Ich würde gerne wissen, mal gucken ob da noch ein Video, ich würde gerne wissen, was
der da drauf hat.
Okay, das ist der richtige Technik Giga Chat.
Ich sag euch Leute, alle Leute, die ein teures Oszilloskop daheim haben, da weißt du Bescheid.
Ja was er da drauf hat?
Ja was er damit macht, würde mich auch interessieren, aber da gibt es anscheinend kein Video zu.
Ich habe so rausgehört, er hat halt da sein restliches Hau- was geht denn da?
Mehr Cat Content.
Also, mich interessiert halt immer, was die Leute damit machen.
Er hat jetzt gesagt, er hat da ein paar Kameras dran angebunden und halt auch die anderen
Räume in seinem Haus, wo ein bisschen Technik steht, aber das Netzwerkequipment ist super
high, high äh.
Naja, okay.
Ich muss das ein bisschen relativieren.
Für den Heimbereich super high Performance, ja.
Der hat zwischen den ganzen unterschiedlichen Verteilen, hat der 10 Gig Glasfaser liegen
und alles.
Da ist halt immer die Frage, was ist denn da dran, dass das alles braucht?
Überhauptest mal das, dass das ein Hobby ist?
Ja, bestimmt.
Gebastelt ist auch mein Hobby, aber für mich lohnt sich das preis-leistungstechnisch alles
nicht.
Okay.
Also, ich hab auch 10 Gig am Start, allerdings bei mir geht 10 Gig eigentlich nur bei mir
ins Arbeitszimmer.
Es geht zum NAS, ja, es geht zu einem zweiten Switch, der hier neben mir steht auf der linken
Seite an, an, an meiner, meinem Bastel-, Basteltisch.
Und es geht 10 Gig an meinen Desktop-Rechner.
Das war's.
Potenziell könnte 10 Gig auch noch ins Erdgeschoss und in den Keller gehen.
Da liegt ein Kabel dafür da.
Aber, da hab ich nix, was in irgendeiner Art und Weise 10 Gig bräuchte.
Weiß nicht.
Ich muss mir jetzt...
jetzt noch ein bisschen, ein bisschen Cat-Content
angucken. Geht nur drei Minuten.
Do you still
want to take this? Ach, ist das eine
Modelleisenbahn?
Oh, das finden die ja super spannend,
könnte ich mir vorstellen, wenn da so
was Kleines im Kreis rumsaust.
Ja.
Oh, da
wäre meine drauf abgegangen.
Genauso hätte die da auch
davor gesetzt. Also, was Chico
am liebsten gemacht hat, Chico, Chico
ist die hier unten, die hier unten
rechts. Was Chico am liebsten
gemacht hat, ist, Laserpointer fand die
gar nicht mal so geil, weil das konnte man nicht richtig
fangen. Was Chico am liebsten gemacht
hat bei solchen Spielchen ist, ich hab
so einen Tunnel gekauft, der lag
im Wohnzimmer, so einen Plastiktunnel
und da
hat die sich teilweise hinter den Tunnel gesetzt
und da wusste ich, ich muss mit der jetzt, wir gucken, durch
den Tunnel spielen.
Und da musste ich immer auf die
andere Seite vom Tunnel und da durchgucken
und dann wieder weg
und dann wieder durchgucken und dann wieder weg
und da saß die dann auch auf der anderen Seite
so dahinter, so
es bewegt sich, es bewegt sich
und irgendwann
musstest du aufpassen, irgendwann hat die
von 0 auf 100 beschleunigt
und ist dir entgegengesprintet durch den Tunnel.
Da musstest du dann nach Möglichkeit nicht
gerade dein Face davor haben.
Ich hab dann, wenn ich wusste, dass die losrennt,
hab ich meistens nur meinen Fuß immer noch
davor gemacht, mit Socken drüber, dann konnte
die meinen Fuß fangen. Den Fuß davor
gemacht,
hat ein bisschen gewackelt
und dann ist die wirklich, Katzen haben ja im Prinzip
keine Beschleunigungsdauer.
Die sind von Stillstand auf
Fullspeed, ohne Beschleunigung dazwischen.
Die sind
Infinite G-Force
resistent, hab ich so das Gefühl.
Die brauchen keine Beschleunigung.
Also Chico konnte auch von
0 zu
3 Milliarden kmh
durch den Tunnel, du hast wirklich
gesehen, Chico ist in Ruhe und Chico
kommt aus dem Tunnel raus. Chico hat im
Prinzip keine Beschleunigungsphase gehabt.
Und dann hat sie sich halt auf den Fuß gestürzt,
weil der musste gefangen werden.
Bremsen funktioniert nicht so gut.
Guckt es euch an.
Die hauen doch jetzt auf den Zug
drauf, oder?
Ja. Hätte mich auch sehr gewundert,
wenn der Zug nicht umgehauen wird.
Da liegt was dickes auf der Strecke.
Nee, gar nicht auf der Strecke.
Oh.
Ja. Ich habe übrigens
gelesen, dass Katzen
das nicht willentlich
steuern können, ihre Pupillen.
Das passiert alles automatisch.
Das ist ein bisschen wie bei euch.
Ihr könnt ja eure Pupillen auch nicht willens...
also absichtlich
steuern. Ihr könnt jetzt auch nicht sagen,
ich mach jetzt meine Pupillen schmal oder...
Das passiert automatisch. Mit Chico habe ich
immer noch... Ich hab doch irgendwie sowas...
Äh... äh...
Wo ist denn das Video mit den Katzen?
Wo hab ich das hier?
Ich müsste mal ein Video machen, das ist schon jetzt... äh...
zwei, drei Monate her.
Wo ist das Video mit...
Wenn einer ein Video sieht, wo Chico drauf ist,
sagt Bescheid.
Alter, wie ich mich gequält hab
bei diesem Drecksvideo, ähm...
Ich hab so keinen Bock, das zu machen.
Da ist Chef für ein Jahr.
Äh...
Ja.
Hallo, Leute.
Ja. So.
Das, das, das musste ich mit Chico
manchmal spielen hier.
Sie lag auf dem Bett neben mir.
Und...
Dann ging
das Ganze so. Guck.
Guckt euch, guckt euch meinen Arm an.
Ich musste schon ein paar mal machen, ja.
Das war gefährlich.
So, und gleich hat sie keinen Bock mehr.
So, so Dinger musste ich, musste ich mit
Chico machen.
Lass mich in Ruhe.
Und dann ist sie ab und zu von 0 auf 100
weggesprintet
irgendwo anders hin.
Ich glaube jetzt, ich glaube jetzt sprintet sie auch gleich weg.
Guck, jetzt, jetzt reflektiert
irgendwas. Was ist da los?
Ja, das ist die andere.
Es war so klar, dass der Zug umgehauen werden muss.
Die sind aber niedlich, die zwei.
Okay, so Halsbänder
mögen sie eigentlich gar nicht.
Modelleisen mal im Homelab.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Übrigens, sorry, Leute, falls ich irgendwas im Chat übersehen hab,
schreibt es nochmal mit Edwublos, sollte ich was übersehen haben.
Da ist sie. Und...
Und...
Ist das hier irgendein japanischer
Modelleisenbahnclub
oder?
Oh, da unten. Sie hat's anvisiert.
Gleich.
Oh, oh.
Chat, wisst ihr, was ich über sowas
immer denke?
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr seid eine Maus.
Und ihr seht sowas,
wenn ihr aus eurem Loch guckt.
Da scheißt ihr euch ganz schön in die
Hose, oder?
In den USA sind Kinderzimmer-Provider
nicht unüblich. Das könnte das Nutzen
des krassen Hommels sein.
Was sind Kinderzimmer-Provider?
Du meinst, dass die irgendwie ein Netzwerk
für andere Leute in der Nachbarschaft bereitstellen?
1&1!
Ich glaube, 1&1 sieht sich zumindest selbst nicht so.
Ich hab tatsächlich bei 1&1 schon ganz
jahrelang einen Server. Sorry, IONOS.
Nicht 1&1, aber das ist glaube ich der gleiche Laden, oder?
Oder war IONOS Strato?
Da hab ich einen
1 Dollar, einen 1 Euro, sorry,
einen 1 Euro Server.
Und der ist auch
seit Jahren tatsächlich 1 Euro.
Eine feste IPv4-Adresse, was das
Wertvollste an dem ganzen Ding ist.
Oh, die sind aber
auch niedlich, die zwei da, oder?
Guck mal.
IONOS 1&1,
okay.
Das ist super krass Entertainment für die
Katzen. Ich glaube, die sind
happy.
Als Maus machst du dir in die
Hose, wenn du
aus der Maus noch guckst und siehst sowas
davor.
Katzen kacken dich einfach random irgendwo hin.
Es sei denn, sie haben irgendwas.
Nicht erwischt.
Zu lahm.
Die können aber auch
gucken, die zwei.
Bam, jawoll!
Stell dir vor, du wirst
auf Mausgröße geschrumpft, was sie dann mit dir
machen würde. Die würde so lange auf mich
draufhauen, oder vielleicht auch mich
reinbeißen, bis ich halb tot bin und mich dann
liegen lassen.
Die zwei sind aber auch
echt niedlich.
Keine Ahnung, dass du so lange
ohne Katze aushältst.
Chico ist im Dezember gestorben,
das sind jetzt vier Monate. Mal gucken.
Früher oder später hole ich mir schon wieder
eine.
Okay, das war
sehr wichtig, dass wir das jetzt geguckt haben.
Jetzt kriege ich wahrscheinlich, dadurch, dass
ich mir das angeguckt habe, hört es wahrscheinlich gar nicht
mehr auf, mir sowas zu erzählen. Was haben wir denn hier?
Secret Homelab.
Okay, ich...
Moment, das ist...
Pass auf, das ist jetzt Modelleisenbahn
und Homelab in einem.
YouTube Alg...
Der YouTube Algorithmus ist feifert.
Der YouTube Algorithmus hat festgestellt,
Katzen, Homelab,
Modelleisenbahn
und jetzt kommt Homelab mit Katzen
und Modelleisenbahn als nächstes.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch? Was ist das?
Most popular computer
operating system 1985
bis 2024.
Wie will...
Die Frage ist...
Ist da Mobile drinne?
Oder nicht?
Also meint er mit Computer,
Desktop oder halt Computer in Form
von, ja, Universal.
Also, wenn Mobile drinne
ist, dann sieht es anders aus
als das, was ich jetzt sagen würde. Ansonsten
ist die Sache halt relativ easy, ja.
Windows
11, beziehungsweise
ich glaube, es ist immer noch Windows 10, ne?
Windows 10, gefolgt von Windows 11,
Mac
und irgendwann, oder
vielleicht dazwischen noch ein paar andere Windows-Versionen
und irgendwo Linux.
Aber wir sind uns ja
einig, 2024 wird das Jahr
des Linux-Desktops.
Eindeutig.
Gut, dass
Unix sinkt und DOS
steigt, liegt auch daran,
dass Heimcomputer sich
immer mehr etablieren.
Ich meine,
hier noch nicht so extrem,
aber das kommt dann so die nächsten
zehn Jahre, geht es ja richtig krass durch die Decke.
96 hat gefühlt
fast jeder Zweite so
irgendwie einen daheim und 86
war das schon auch ein bisschen,
ja, ein bisschen was Seltenes.
Aber davor
waren das ja alles irgendwelche
Uni-Ausstattung,
Großrechner oder sonst wie.
Was ist VMS?
Ich habe
keine Ahnung.
Latest release
three months ago.
Ein Maskottchen haben sie schon mal.
Gucken wir mal, wie das 2023 aussieht.
Das sieht aus, ein bisschen aus
wie eine IBM-Host-Konsole.
Okay, supermoderner Shit.
Habe ich noch nie was von gehört, bis jetzt.
DOS 4.0 ist
Open Source. Aha.
Weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, ob das irgendwie
eine Bedeutung hat, in der heutigen Zeit.
Dass das irgendjemand was bringt.
Man kann sich das angucken, ja.
So eher aus historischen Gründen.
Irgendwann kommt dann auch nochmal
Amiga. Ach ne, Amiga ist schon hier am Start.
OS 2.
Ja, da hat sich IBM
auch leicht verkalkuliert.
Und OS 2 ist schon wieder weg.
Ne, da ist es.
Oh, jetzt wird es langsam Zeit für Windows.
Jawoll, da ist es.
Ja, in den nächsten Jahren
wird Windows super
heftig an DOS vorbeiziehen.
Wobei, ich weiß nicht, wie sie es rechnen.
Man muss ja dazu sagen, dass jeder
Windows 3.11, 3.1, wie auch immer rechnet,
der hat ja noch einen DOS drunter.
Wo glaubst du, haben die solche Daten her?
Das steht meistens hier unten drunter.
Also, das kommt garantiert
Data is beautiful subreddit.
Hätte ich jetzt vermutet.
Und da kann man eigentlich immer gucken, wo die das herhaben.
Set counter.
Ja, mein aktuell steigt DOS
und Windows, weil DOS Voraussetzung ist
für Windows.
So kann man so noch Windows gar nicht an DOS
vorbeiziehen.
Windows NT, Mac.
Mac ist halt bei den Amis auch saubeliebt.
Wird man, glaube ich, also...
Ja, jetzt.
Jetzt ist es vorbei.
Windows 95 war tatsächlich ein riesengroßer
Wurf für die damals.
Das ging so durch die Decke.
Aber das stimmt nicht,
Windows 95 hat auch noch DOS als Unterbau.
Also, das passt ja so gar nicht
richtig dann.
Das ist innerhalb von ein paar Jahren.
Das ging einfach durch die Decke.
Okay, die zählen Windows 95 nur als Windows
und nicht als DOS und Windows.
OS 2 ist halt einfach wieder weg.
Ja gut, jetzt
sehen wir ein paar Windows-Versionen, die sich abwechseln.
Jetzt gleich gibt es mal einen ganz kurzen
Spike Windows ME
und der ist dann auch relativ schnell wieder weg.
Der spiked, glaube ich, noch nicht mal Windows ME.
Der taucht
erstmal gar nicht auf.
Ich möchte mal Windows 2000 kommen.
Windows 2000 ist ja quasi so
der eigentliche Vorgänger von dem,
was wir heute verwenden.
Ja, Windows 2000.
Das macht YouTube automatisch, wenn ich Pause drücke.
XP, ja.
Ja.
XP wird lange da bleiben.
Dann kommt mal kurz
Windows 7, was auch ganz gut abgeht.
Aber Windows 8 wird es dann
verkacken.
Alter, was ist mit der Musik los jetzt?
Ich bin ja immer noch der Meinung,
Windows XP war das beste Windows.
Jetzt nicht so in der Form, dass ich das heute noch
verwenden wollen würde.
Aber Windows XP war das letzte Windows,
was irgendwie aus einem Guss
erschien.
Danach war es gefrickelt as fuck.
Ich fand da auch, Windows XP
hatte was Eigenes.
Das war so eine bisschen comic-hafte Oberfläche.
Heute sieht das so
so kühl
und zu clean aus.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Mobile
dazu kommt.
2007 wissen wir es.
2007 geht der ganze Smartphone-Krempel
so richtig los.
Aber ich gehe nicht davon aus,
dass Mobile dabei ist.
Computer Operating Systems.
Willst du sagen, dass ein Smartphone kein Computer ist?
Ja, Windows XP.
Linux Giga Chat Time.
Weil wenn es auch Server
mit einbezieht, ja.
Was es anscheinend nicht wirklich macht
hier.
Sondern nur Desktop-Computer.
Dann müsste Linux
jetzt tatsächlich langsam anfangen durch die Decke
zu gehen.
Das Internet läuft auf Linux.
Mal
übertrieben gesagt.
Und es kommt bald Windows 7
irgendwann.
Ach nee, sorry, sorry.
Vista. Ich habe es ja ganz vergessen.
Wir hatten ja erst noch Vista.
Ah ja, jetzt Windows 7. Windows 7 geht
gut ab.
Ob das damit zusammenhängt, dass
Linux mal kurz ein bisschen
hoch und jetzt runter geht,
weil Windows Vista so schlecht ankam?
Aber so 2007
rum gab es mit Ubuntu
und Compits auch richtig coole
Oberfläche.
Also Ubuntu, das war damals noch ein Gnome Desktop.
Gnome mit Compits unter Ubuntu.
Das war aus meiner Sicht
das Peak. Peak
Linux Desktop.
Die damalige Gnome
Version plus Compits.
Und das Ubuntu halt einfach
so ein Ding war, was
gut funktioniert hat.
Das war Peak Linux Desktop
aus meiner Sicht.
Gerade Compits.
Compits war so nice.
Und war so der Hingucker,
was sonst keiner
einfach hatte.
Ausbildung 2007.
Windows 7, ja. Geht rauf.
Ja, Windows 8 wollte ja keiner
haben.
Guck mal, immer wenn eine neue scheiß
Windows Version rauskommt, geht die
Linux-Verbreitung hoch.
Nee, Ubuntu mag ich heute gar nicht mehr.
Noch nicht mal mehr auf dem Server.
Ich war lange Zeit mal
Windows Server, ja ganz bestimmt.
Lange Zeit Ubuntu Server
Fan.
Aber da bin ich auch wieder weg von.
Kommt Debian und fertig.
Debian only.
Und auf dem Desktop Arch btw.
Warum ist MS-DOS
vor MacOS?
Legacy Zeug, hier oben ist ja immer noch OSX.
Ok, Windows 10.
Windows 10 wird das natürlich
auch ein bisschen brauchen,
aber dann auf Platz 1 landen
am Ende.
Linux legt auch wieder ein bisschen zu.
Weil streng genommen ist Linux schon
Unix-like.
Wo ist Windows 9 geblieben?
Das weiß nur Microsoft.
Ich glaube tatsächlich,
dass Linux mit ein bisschen mehr, als es jetzt ist.
Enden wird, hier bei 2023.
Aber ich meine,
es wird sein, letztendlich
Windows 10 vorne, gefolgt von
Windows 11, denke ich mal.
Und dann Mac
und dann Linux.
Eventuell noch ein paar Mac-Versionen
zwischen Linux.
Wobei, ich weiß gar nicht,
bis wann die Daten gehen.
Vielleicht ist Windows 11 auch gar nicht so weit oben mit dabei.
Chrome OS kann auch wieder verschwinden.
Wobei man fairnesshalber
sagen muss, dass Browser heute
eigentlich schon
als eigenes Betriebssystem durchgehen.
Und angeblich,
man weiß es ja nicht genau,
angeblich hat
Chrome mittlerweile fünfmal mehr
Source-Code als
Windows 11.
Habe ich gelesen. Man kann es nicht wirklich nachvollziehen,
ob das stimmt. Aber ich kann es mir schon
vorstellen. DOS?
Klar, beispielsweise auf alten Geldautomaten
und sowas. Okay, im Prinzip
ist es so, wie ich mir das gedacht habe.
Genau das habe ich vorausgesagt, oder?
Genau das habe ich gesagt.
Windows 10, gefolgt von Windows 11,
gefolgt von Mac, gefolgt von Linux.
Wobei ich ja persönlich vermutet hätte,
dass noch ein paar Windows-Versionen
zwischen Linux und dem Kram hier liegen.
Aber, ja.
Was heißt, was ich vorausgesagt habe?
Ist ja Blödsinn.
Ich sehe das ja aktuell.
Es ist nichts, was ich jetzt predicted hätte,
sondern anhand dessen, wie es sich halt
aktuell aussieht.
Wie gesagt, so müsste es sein.
Ja. Ja.
So hätte ich das auch vermutet.
Interessant wäre, ob es das Ganze noch für
Serverbetriebssysteme gibt.
Linux hat sich in den letzten zwei Jahren verdoppelt.
Ja, das hängt immer ein bisschen auch ab,
wie die Quellen das zählen und so.
Aber kann ich mir schon vorstellen?
Weil viele Leute sind ja schon ein bisschen pisst.
Und durch die Initiative,
gerade was
ähm, was Valve angeht
und Steam und Games
und auch die Möglichkeit,
was gerade
Videobearbeitung sowas angeht
und auch
Sachen wie Blender und so, dass das ja immer
etablierter ist alles.
Das hat schon dazu beigetragen,
dass viele Leute Linux
mehr verwenden.
Ich meine, ich verwende auch Linux.
Täglich.
Und je nachdem, was ich mache,
mehr als Windows.
Wenn man die Arbeit weglässt.
Ja, auf der Arbeit ist es halt
Windows und Linux halt auch, aber
ähm, da verdiene ich halt mein Geld
letztendlich mit Linux.
Aber ich muss immer noch so einen hässlichen
Windows-Laptop benutzen,
den ich zum Glück
eigentlich nur als VPN-Endpunkt brauche.
Ja.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich Package-Updates gemacht heute?
Ja, oder?
Ne, doch.
Arch, by the way. Ich hatte doch heute Morgen schon
Package-Updates gemacht, oder?
Aber Arch Linux hat natürlich schon wieder neue
Package-Updates.
Und das sage ich jetzt so objektiv,
wie es geht. Deswegen sage ich auch
aus meiner Sicht, ja.
Wenn man gerne bastelt
und
Software entwickelt,
das nicht jetzt irgendwie exklusiv Windows
ist,
es führt kein Weg daran vorbei, entweder
Linux zu benutzen
oder meinetwegen
MacOS. MacOS
ist Linux- bzw. Unix-
artig genug.
Ist ja im Kern ein BSD.
Ein Free-BSD.
Und da ist
Windows not even close.
Allein schon, dass man hier
ein ordentliches Terminal und eine ordentliche
Shell hat. Und ein System,
was sich auch so anfühlt, als ist es
dafür gedacht, so benutzt zu werden.
Selbst
WSL kommt da nicht ran.
Mit WSL hast du immer so kleinen Scheiß,
der dir auf den Sack geht.
Visual Studio-Enjoyer. Aber wozu braucht man noch
Visual Studio? Visual Studio brauchst du doch für nichts
mehr. Visual Studio brauchst du
vielleicht, wenn du Windows-only für Windows-Programme
unterwegs bist, aber selbst da
würde ich unter Windows
mittlerweile hauptsächlich Rider benutzen
für .NET-Entwicklung
oder irgendwelche anderen
JetBrains-Kram für die üblichen
größeren
Sprachen.
Wenn jetzt einer
sagen wir, was auch immer
Java macht,
IntelliJ oder so.
Und Rider unterstützt nicht alles, was Visual Studio
unterstützt. Das mag sein, aber
was Relevantes
unterstützen die denn nicht?
Wenn wir mal von Windows-only Sachen ausgehen,
wo du eh am besten unter Windows.
Service Fabric, okay.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was Service Fabric
ist, aber wenn es das nicht unterstützt.
Azure Service Fabric.
Ja, das
ist vielleicht sogar gut, dass die das nicht unterstützen.
Warum muss Visual Studio das unterstützen?
Warum braucht
Visual Studio eine Unterstützung für die
Kubernetes-Geschichte von Microsoft?
Hä? Man baut in der
IDE seine Software
und am Ende hast du dann vielleicht
irgendeinen
Terraform, was hier den Kram aufbaut
und irgendwas darüber. Das brauchst du
keine IDE-Unterstützung.
Also ich brauch's nicht
und ich mach gerne was in .NET.
Was trinken jetzt?
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Alter!
Was war das jetzt?
Ich übersetz... What the hell?
Passiv-Aggressiv.
Ich brauch ein Logar-Python. Passiv-Aggressiv.
Ey! Das ist so ein typischer Fall von
Warum macht man die Bedienung auf dem Desktop
so kacke? Oh, ich hab
gerade eine Scam-SMS
bekommen.
Sehr geehrter Kunde, für den Versand Ihrer Sendung
fallen Zollgebühren an.
Bitte, weitere Details
finden Sie hier.
Okay, Spam melden.
Spam löschen und melden.
Klingt legit. Ja.
Ehrlich.
Passiv-Aggressive E-Mails und ihre Bedeutung.
Nach meiner Recherche...
Man kann das immer gut...
Man kann da immer was Böswilliges reininterpretieren.
Nach meiner Recherche
heißt, also wenn die Leute da schreiben,
heißt das meistens so viel wie
Ich hab nachgeguckt
und ich hab voll den Durchblick
und ich bin vor allem
und das Konzern hat das nicht geschrieben
und ich bin vor allem zu einem anderen Schluss
gekommen als du.
Ich habe mich informiert,
ich habe Recht und du liegst falsch.
Und ich zeige dir jetzt, warum du falsch liegst. Du Vollidiot.
Wie können wir so etwas in Zukunft verhindern?
Das bedeutet so viel wie, mach das nie wieder.
Das würde ich nicht so sehen.
Das sehe ich nicht so.
Wie können wir das...
Es kommt immer drauf an, in welchem
ähm...
Rahmen das fällt.
Aber sagen wir mal, wenn das jetzt...
Mal angenommen, es ist wirklich was kaputt gegangen
und man sitzt da mit
irgendwie 10 Leuten zusammen
und das Thema ist, wie können wir sowas in Zukunft verhindern?
Würde ich das nicht passiv-aggressiv
gegen mich deuten?
Wenn es natürlich einer
exklusiv nur an mich schreibt,
okay, vielleicht.
Aber es kann mich auch jemand fragen
zu was, wo ich nix mit...
Also kommt auf den Kontext an.
Und es wirkt so, als würde der Verfasser dir helfen wollen
bei deinem Problem, aber das will er nicht.
Mach es einfach nie wieder.
Okay, mein Chef ist jetzt in CC,
bedeutet, leck mich, ähm...
Ich hab keinen Bock mehr mit dir rumzuzackern
hier, rumzudiskutieren.
Bam, ich hab jetzt meinen Chef in CC.
Das ist eine offizielle Kriegserklärung.
In dem Fall solltest du schnell nachlegen
und ebenfalls Leute in CC nehmen.
Wichtig.
Das wollte ich auch gerade sagen.
Am besten einfach Gesamt-IT in CC.
Ich habe es auf dem Schirm,
das bedeutet so viel wie...
Chat, seid ihr da auch immer dran?
Da sind wir dran.
Ich nehme das mit.
Wir sind dran.
... als wäre ich ein kleines Kind und lass mich in Ruhe.
Ich werde es aber trotzdem vergessen, wahrscheinlich.
Naja...
... gibt es schon etwas Neues, das bedeutet so viel wie
Warum brauchst du solange, ich habe die schon vor fünf Tagen geschrien...
Nee, das stimmt nicht.
Ich frag das auch schon,
ich frag dann sowas wie, hast du schon was Neues gehört, oder so.
wie das mehr machen als was anderes.
Oftmals einfach nur, weil ich wissen will,
ob jemand anderes dann schon drauf reagiert hat.
Die hängen ja auch, das ist ja oftmals
auch wieder abhängig von irgendjemand.
Das ist, das sehe ich gar nicht so.
Kommt natürlich
ein bisschen auf den Kontext an, wie bei vielen Sachen
der Kontext macht.
Wie bereits erwähnt, bedeutet so viel wie,
du Vollidiot hast meine letzte Mail scheinbar nicht verstanden,
weil du dumm bist oder nicht lesen kannst.
Also lass es mich nochmal wiederholen, damit auch du es verstehst.
Du Vollidiot. Korrigier mich, wenn ich falsch liege.
Das bedeutet so viel wie, ich liege definitiv
nicht falsch, aber ich will höflich klingen.
Das sage ich aber tatsächlich auch öfters.
Korrigier mich, wenn ich falsch liege.
Wobei ich das tatsächlich so meine.
Vielleicht kommt das auch nicht so an.
Also, ne, also
gerade wenn ich von dem Thema jetzt nicht primär
so die Ahnung habe oder teilweise
gar nicht dabei gewesen bin,
das ist ja auch sowas wie, korrigiert mich, ja,
ich war da nicht dabei, aber ich habe gehört, dass
finde ich gar nicht so schlimm.
Naja.
Also in den meisten Sachen stimme ich aber zu.
Okay, dann gucken wir nochmal was
Robert in seinem
Secret Homelab hat.
Äh, ist das
40 Gig QSFP?
Oder was sehe ich da, Chatge? Wer kennt sich damit auch?
Äh, wer kennt sich damit auch aus?
Oder noch auch aus? Wer kennt sich
damit noch aus? Gut, ich kann wieder
keinen Satz bilden, Alter.
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Das ist ein SAS-Anschluss, das ist kein QSFP.
Senior IT-Experte, by the way.
Okay, IT, das kenne ich.
Das sind so, ähm, das sind für die
SAS-Controller, beziehungsweise für RAID-Controller
sind das so verschiedene Firmwares,
die es gibt, je nachdem
wie die, wie
das Betriebssystem die Platten präsentiert kriegt.
Also quasi direkt durchgemappt
oder eben nur das, was auf dem,
auf der Karte angelegt ist und sowas.
Ich glaube, IT-Mode ist das, wenn du willst,
dass das,
wo es die Platten
sieht, wie wenn sie quasi auch
sagen wir mal, per SATA direkt
angestöpselt wären, ohne irgendwelche
Logik noch vom Controller.
Da macht im Prinzip der Controller wirklich nur
das physische Attachen
und Adressieren. Also keine,
keine Hardware-RAID.
Ja, ja, so einen hatte ich
in der alten Kiste auch drin, ne?
Ja.
Nee, das war ein Mini, so ein Mini-SAS-Connector
hatte ich da.
Acht? Ja.
Ist das ein Schwede?
Irgendwie hört er an Finne?
Hört sich eben so ein bisschen skandinavisch an.
Ich habe an guten Features.
Auf das Case, das ist, das ist ein
Fractal Design R5 oder so was,
das Case.
Übrigens, ich mag sein Hemd-Joyce.
So Dinge habe ich auch gerne an.
Ich persönlich bin ein großer Fan von.
Wie heißt das auf Deutsch? Wechselrahmen?
Wobei das hier irgendwo auch geht, wenn man nur die Seite,
wenn man nur die Seite vom Gehäuse abmachen muss. Ja.
Rahmen, am besten vorne in der Front, wo du dann solche Trays hast zum rein und raus schieben,
die halt auch eine Backplane haben, die Hotswappable ist, weil das eventuell, also hier ist halt
keine, hier musst du halt beide Seiten aufmachen, dass du die Platte ordentlich rausbekommst
und was auch schwierig ist in dem Fall zu erkennen, wenn eine Platte kaputt ist, welche
Platte kaputt ist, das heißt eigentlich musst du dir ein Mapping bauen, weil im Betriebssystem
siehst du ja dann vielleicht der Port, der kaputt ist oder vielleicht hast du noch so
eine Sache mit Seriennummer oder so, die du dann noch siehst oder irgendwas, es ist immer
schwierig das zuzuordnen, wenn du in deinem Betriebssystem siehst, Platte, da steht dann
so SDF ist kaputt, ja okay, nice, welche ist SDF, das ist ja nicht so unbedingt von unten
nach oben immer, also oftmals ist halt gut, man braucht irgendein Mapping, Linux, Linux
hat ja mehrere Möglichkeiten, wie du eine Platte ansprechen kannst, das sollte man vielleicht
auch mal zeigen, ja, du hast sowas wie def, äh, jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, by ID, Moment,
äh, disk, genau, du hast disk by ID, disk by label, disk by links, disk by path, da hast
du manchmal die Chance noch ein bisschen was rauszuerkennen, welche, welche kaputt gegangen
ist, ja, und dann siehst du oftmals auch in deinem Kernel-Log drinnen, aber die Zuordnung
welche der Platten hier, ist dann gar nicht so einfach, da bleibt dir oftmals bloß, bloß
übrig, zum Beispiel hier eine ID draufzuschreiben mit einem, mit so einem dicken Edding oder
irgendwie die zu merken, okay, welche Seriennummer wo dran ist, das ist halt das Coole an so
NAS Cases mit LEDs an den Wechselrahmen, wobei es dann, wenn du, wenn du nicht das vom Hersteller
vorgesehene verwendest, es auch sehr schwierig ist.
Die Kommunikation zwischen deinem PC und dem Wechselrahmen und für LEDs, das geht
über ein Protokoll, das nennt sich SGPIO, SGPIO, das ist für solche Festplatten, Trays
und, und Backplanes gedacht, da kann man dann signalisieren, welche Platte kaputt ist, die
heißt Synology, Synology kann das halt, weil das alles von einem Hersteller kommt, das
ist schwarze Magie, Leute, das ist echt schwarze Magie.
Ich habe mich damit mal ein bisschen beschäftigt, das ist aber echt komplett für den Arsch.
Und das ist so für den Arsch, dass ich sagen würde, es ist für ein Eigenbausystem gar
nicht so, also ohne weiteres möglich, die Wechselrahmen gescheit mit LEDs anzusteuern.
Da ist es sicherlich einfacher, man baut sich selbst was mit einem, mit irgendeinem Microcontroller,
der per USB dranhängt und irgendwie einem Skript, was das dann checkt, was ist kaputt,
welche Seriennummer war das, wo ist die drin?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da mittlerweile was Besseres gibt.
Also das ist halt immer schwierig bei, was ich sagen will, es ist oftmals schwierig,
festzustellen, welche Platte wirklich hiervon jetzt kaputt ist, nach einer Meldung von deinem
OS.
Ja, Seriennummer zu Ports, das ist das einzige, was du machen kannst, ja.
Oh, hübsch.
Übrigens, warum ist das hier ein Homelab, das ist ein Rechner.
Warum steht bei dir in der Url immer eine 1, wenn sie markiert ist?
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen 1 im Chat, da versuche ich das zu erklären.
Oh nein, alles ist voll.
Was soll ich tun?
Humongous Cockers!
98 Terabytes.
Fuck, das ist viel Raum.
Verdammt, es sind nicht 100 Terabytes.
Zwei Schrauben sind verloren.
Parody.
Also fast.
Zwei Schrauben verloren zu Parody, ist das in Raid 6?
Dann.
Aber mit wieviel Platten, wobei, es sind gar nicht so viele Platten, das sind wahrscheinlich
einfach 12 oder 14 Terabyte, ich habe das jetzt gar nicht geguckt, was für Platten
hat er da drinnen?
Steiner, danke schön für den Sub.
18, äh 8, 8 mal 18, ja, geht doch eigentlich, ist doch eigentlich ganz okay, ja mit 8 Platten,
mit 8 Platten kann man auch ein Raid 6 machen.
Ich vermute mal, Raid 6 ist das erste, was mir einfällt für Parody, mit 2, mit 2 Platten.
Also in Raid 5 würde ich definitiv nicht über 8 oder gar 12 Platten machen, da möchtest
du eigentlich Datenverlust haben mit einem Raid 5, bei so vielen Platten, also der Datenverlust
ist wahrscheinlicher mit einem Raid 5, in dem Fall wie bei einem, ja, also es ist wahrscheinlicher,
dass was kaputt geht, als dass was nicht kaputt geht.
Almost.
A lot of terrible, terrible things have happened in my closet.
It's the perfect home for my monster.
That's right.
We're also stuffing my closet.
I've always wanted to install a little server rack somewhere.
Ja, gute Idee.
And it needed a little bit of prep work.
Das ist eine echte Lösung.
When I started this project, it was impossible to find some plywood.
How can we be honest?
Out of plywood.
I used some oak shelf units.
It worked out fine.
Kann man so machen.
The best way to keep the monst- Das allerwichtigste, LED-Strips.
... at bay is to put LED-Strips inside of your closet.
Logisch, also ohne LED-Beleuchtung ist es unmöglich, so einen Serverrack zu betreiben
mittlerweile.
Nice.
I should almost do this in my other closet, when I'm picking out my clothing.
Cool.
Gonna put a power brick in first.
To power all the devices we're gonna put in here.
The first thing we are going to need is organization.
So here we have a keystone patch panel.
Glücklicherweise benutzen immer mehr Leute Keystone-Patch-Panels.
Es sind ja gar keine Patch-Panels.
Kommt drauf an, was du damit machst.
Aber zum Glücklicherweise benutzen immer mehr Leute Keystone-Panels.
Hab ich auch.
Ist super.
Freuen mich ja in fünf Spielen an.
I know.
For all of the network cables.
Ich glaube, ich habe sogar genau exakt das Gleiche.
I am getting some plastic keystones.
Might not be the best, but it's been working just fine for me.
Es ist top.
It's like the little Legos of networking.
Das ist das Gute, ich habe es das letzte Mal schon gesagt, das Gute an diesen Keystone-Dinger
ist, dass es da verschiedene Einsätze gibt.
Du kriegst nicht nur Netzwerkstecker-Einsätze, sondern du kriegst auch für LC-Stecker,
sind das glaube ich, für Glasfaser, für USB.
Ach, weiß ich nicht.
Ist das so?
Es gibt HDMI, genau.
Es gibt Keystone quasi für nahezu alle Sachen.
Da kann man quasi auch, wenn man was anderes mal ein bisschen durchs Rack ziehen muss,
als Netzwerkkabel, ist das sehr praktisch.
Und die Netzwerkstecker gibt es halt auch als vorne und hinten in RJ45 oder nur vorne
in RJ45, hinten zum Selbstpatchen.
Da gibt es auch die guten Sachen.
Hier, Keystone.
Da gibt es die mit dieser Klemme hinten.
Ja, genau, die da.
Die sind sehr nice.
Da kann man, da ist so eine Einführhilfe dabei.
Hier so was.
Da macht man das rein.
Gibt es auch in verschiedenen Ausprägungen.
Aber da ist das Patchen von den Kabeln relativ easy.
Da packst du die Kabel so rein, steckst das hier rein, dass da oben sind kleine Klingen,
die man da sieht.
Hier, da, guck da.
Das sind so kleine Klingen.
Da schiebt man das rein.
Und durch das Zuklappen dieses Kopfs hier, da, drückt sich das dann hier quasi richtig,
richtig in die Messer rein und patcht die Kabel sich selbst.
Das ist viel einfacher, als mit Auflegewerkzeug irgendwas auf Patchpanels klemmen und so.
Ja.
Also das ist, das ist nice.
Und da hinten kannst du einen Kabelbinder drum machen noch.
Finde das, finde das gut.
Just click them in.
Lohnt sich das für 10 cm Glasfaser?
Nö.
10 cm Glasfaser heißt ja im Endeffekt, du musst auf kein Patchpanel, du gehst von einer
Kiste auf die andere Kiste und gut ist.
Das lohnt sich, das lohnt sich zum Beispiel, wenn du von einer Kiste Glasfaser da drauf
patchst und dahinter dann quasi im, im Rack quasi innen drinne.
Boah.
Niese, ne.
Vom Rack hinten beispielsweise weiter gehst, irgendwo auf, ja, auf dem Kabelkanal, wo es
dann in die Decke reingeht und so.
Genau.
Und außerdem, das ist richtig, 10 cm nimmst du ein Direct Attached Kabel und kein Glasfaserkabel.
Ich würde eh prinzipiell für alles ein Direct Attached Kabel nehmen, wo es die Länge hergibt.
Ist einfach, einfach eine Handhabung, geht nicht so schnell kaputt und ist viel billiger,
weil du keine zwei Module brauchst.
It almost looks like I know what I'm doing.
There's probably a bunch of viewers that does this video.
Viewers that does this stuff for a living and I do pity you.
Making network cables is inhumane.
My fingers still.
Die Seite mache ich ja auch nicht selbst.
Ich würde nur die andere Seite selbst machen.
If you wanna crimp your own network cables, follow that color combination.
There's better.
Es gibt auch zwei Standards für Netzwerkstecker.
Videos to watch then mine for this.
So.
Go, oh, go away.
Ah, da bin ich so ordentliche Knipex-Zange.
Die ja offiziell Knipex heißen, aber jeder sagt Knipex.
Also selbst Netzwerkkabel patchen habe ich letztens erstmal wieder just for fun gemacht mit einem.
Es ist kacke.
Ich würde nie diese Seite selbst patchen, sondern nur die andere in so ein Keystone-Teil rein, wenn es sein muss.
Oder wenn ich schon Kabel habe, die auf beiden Seiten einfach fertig sind,
und ich das aus, dann nehme ich einfach ein Keystone mit beiden Seiten RJ45.
Also es macht eigentlich keinen Sinn, das abzuschneiden.
Außer, ja, warum auch immer.
Warum habe ich das letztens, Moment, lass mal überlegen.
Was war der Grund?
Ah ja, ich weiß, was der Grund war.
Ich weiß, was der Grund war, warum ich das auf einen eigenen Keystone,
Keystone, RJ45-Ding gepatcht habe.
Weil es ein Kabel war.
Ohne Stecker dran.
Und dann hatte ich die Wahl, ich krimp mir so einen eigenen Netzwerkstecker drauf,
oder ich mache mir so ein Keystone-Ding drauf und mache das dann in eine Dose.
Und dann habe ich ein Keystone-Ding drauf gemacht und eine Dose.
Das sieht man übrigens bei mir auch hier oben.
Hoffe ich, hoffe ich.
Äh, lass mal das, ja, ja, hier, hier.
Was ich ein bisschen gesagt habe, ist ja jetzt...
Äh, nee?
Jetzt schon drei Jahre...
Oder doch?
Bin verwirrt.
Ich blicke in meinem eigenen Serverraum nicht durch.
Ach, das ist noch das Alte.
Hier ist die neue Dose, oder?
Ja, hier ist...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich muss kurz reingucken.
Da ist die neue Dose drinne.
Da ist immer noch die alte.
Ich habe kein Video, wo das drin zu sehen ist.
Die Dose ist rausgeflogen.
Das ist noch die alte, gute...
Wie heißt das bei der Telekom?
Erste TAE.
Mit Kupfer, Kupferkabel von der Telekom.
Die ist rausgeflogen.
Und an der Stelle sitzt jetzt so eine Keystone-Dose.
Bisschen, bisschen so wie die zwei hier.
Bisschen, bisschen wie die zwei.
Äh...
Ja.
Und...
Ja, man sieht es hier.
Bisschen wie die zwei.
Und da kam halt nur ein Kabel aus der Wand.
Und da habe ich halt so ein Ding drauf, drauf gefehlt.
Aber die Seite würde ich nie selbst machen, wenn da schon was drauf ist.
Was machst du mit deinem Serverraum?
Da steht ein...
Ähm...
Hier sieht man noch jemanden.
Da habe ich mein Werkzeug drinne.
Da habe ich mal ein bisschen...
Da ist übrigens noch ein neuer Schrank oben drauf hier.
Das ist der mit den großen.
Da oben ist jetzt noch einer drauf mit so kleinen Dingern.
So kleinen Fächern.
Da habe ich mein...
Elektronik-Sensor-Kram drinne sortiert.
Wobei ich das im ganzen Haus mehr oder weniger verteile.
Aber hier sitzt ja Kleinkram drinne.
Werkzeugstelle, 3D-Drucker.
Und unten drunter...
Wobei das nicht mehr aktuell ist.
Unten drunter gibt es dann halt...
Ja, da war ich gerade am Umbauen.
Gibt es einen 10-Gigabit-Switch.
Ich müsste echt mal wieder ein Update-Video machen.
Das sieht schon wieder anders aus.
Guck, hier sieht man auch bei den Keystone-Panels.
Hier sieht man es.
Guck, hier ist ein LC-Stecker drinne für Glasfaserkram.
Keystone.
Keystone-Ding.
Und unten ein USB.
Das ist genau das gleiche hier.
So.
Ein Switch ist da drinne.
Dann...
Haben wir...
Die UniFi-Sachen sind mittlerweile auch rausgeflogen.
Ja, ich müsste echt mal wieder updaten.
Guck mal, hatte ich da noch dicke Arme, ey.
50 Millimeter.
Mittlerweile wie...
Ich habe ohne Scheiß zu dem Zeitpunkt wie jetzt 20 Kilo abgenommen.
Meine Hände sind nicht mehr so...
Rall.
Die Serverkiste, diese 2AE-Kiste, die ich hier selbst zusammengestrickt habe, die ist auch rausgeflogen.
Ist mittlerweile ein HP-Micro-Server.
Hier liegt ein MikroTik 10-Gigabit-Switch noch rum.
Ja.
Letztendlich ist da ein HP-Micro-Server drinne, ein Router, eine Fritzbox, ein Kabelmodem,
10-Gigabit-Switch und ein bisschen PoE für die 2 Access Points.
Fertig.
Wieso hast du keinen UniFi mehr?
Weil UniFi ewig gebraucht hat, ein Feature bereitzustellen, was viele andere Hersteller
schon lange haben und ich irgendwann keinen Bock mehr auf UniFi hatte.
Deswegen.
Aber die APs hast du noch von UniFi?
Ne.
Habe ich nicht.
Ich habe Ruckus-APs mittlerweile.
Ruckus, wie der Ami sagen würde.
Allerdings nicht die allerneuesten, weil 1000 Euro für einen Access Point ist mir dann auch
ein bisschen viel.
Ich habe gebrauchte.
Ich habe die eine oder eineinhalb Generationen älteren.
Ich habe so einen aktuell.
Zwei.
Nicht einen.
Die da.
Habe ich aktuell.
Zwei Stück.
Eine hängt drüben im Wohnzimmer über PoE dran und eine hängt im Keller über PoE dran.
Braucht man dafür einen extra WLAN-Controller?
Nein.
Das übernimmt ein Access Point mit.
Da muss man dann die Unleashed-Firmware, heißt das, aufpacken und dann ist gut.
Was macht Otto Normalmensch mit einem Home-Server?
Kommt drauf an, was der für Anwendungszwecke hat.
Was der braucht.
Also eines der naheliegendsten Sachen ist sicherlich Netzwerkspeicher.
Das haben wahrscheinlich die meisten Leute, die an sowas denken, denken an Netzwerkspeicher.
Ich habe da beispielsweise noch mal eine ganze Home-Automation-Sache drauflaufen.
Ich habe noch einen Zabbix drauflaufen.
Tatsächlich.
Ich habe privat einen Zabbix drauflaufen, der Festplatten-Auslastungen überwacht.
Beispielsweise unter anderem von ein paar Raspberry Pis.
Und der Checked-Off-Services-App-Downsignal.
Der auch einmal nachts so einen Internet-Speedtest macht und in die History schreibt.
Ansonsten läuft da noch die Software für meine Überwachungskameras drauf.
Und ein paar kleine Sachen laufen da noch drauf.
So ein Organisationstool für meine ganzen Bastelsachen, wo was liegt.
Hälsinglänzen.
Soviel.
Es ist hauptsächlich tatsächlich Netzwerkspeicher und mein Smart Home, was da drauf läuft.
Das ist die hauptsächliche Sache.
Und bestimmt noch das eine oder andere, was einfach funktioniert und ich es jetzt schon wieder vergessen habe.
Manche Sachen habe ich auch wieder rausgeschmissen.
Also ich habe beispielsweise kein PyHole mehr und auch kein Ad...
Wie heißt das andere?
AdGuard Home am Start.
Ich habe auch kein Plex oder sonst was, was ja manche Leute für Video-Streaming machen.
Da sehe ich keinen Sinn drin.
Ja, es hält sich in Grenzen.
Ich habe halt das drauf, was ich...
Ah ja, ich habe tatsächlich noch eine Nextcloud.
Auch wenn ich überhaupt kein Nextcloud-Fan bin.
Die verwende ich allerdings rein als CalDAV- und CardDAV-Server für Kontakte.
Und eigentlich auch eher noch aus historischen Gründen.
Eigentlich will ich den gar nicht mehr haben.
Wie gesagt, ich mag Nextcloud nicht sonderlich.
Dann macht das Ding noch Zertifikate.
Reverse-Proxy für alle anderen Services, die ich im Haus habe.
Die auch beispielsweise auf Raspberry Pi laufen.
Also alle Web-Services bei mir haben ja ein gültiges Zertifikat über Let's Encrypt.
Und der läuft da auch drauf.
Also die wichtigsten drei Sachen sind tatsächlich Smart Home, Netzwerk-Storage und Überwachungskameras.
Ich glaube, das war es zum größten Teil.
Was nimmst du als Alternative für Nextcloud?
Naja, ich verwende ja von Nextcloud nichts.
Außer CalDAV.
Und da könnte man auch einen eigenen CalDAV-Server verwenden.
Was es da nicht noch alles gibt.
Bei Cal gibt es dann noch und...
Boah, es gibt ein paar.
Aber ich werde es jetzt als Nextcloud lassen.
Weil ich habe das ja auch schon ewig nicht mehr geupdatet.
Da wird ja wie gesagt, das macht nichts.
Außer ein bisschen Kontakte und Kalender.
Aber ich habe keinen Bock auf Nextcloud mehr.
Also wenn ich da wieder mal ein bisschen was dran rumbaue.
Dann fliegt es raus.
Und vielleicht lasse ich es dann auch ganz.
Vielleicht benutze ich tatsächlich irgendeinen Cloud-Service.
Und importiere meine Kontakte da.
Ich weiß es noch nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Weil ich ja eigentlich sowas nicht gerne mache.
Und die anderen Sachen, die ich so brauche, die laufen tatsächlich ein bisschen dezentral.
Nicht mehr auf dem Heim-Server.
Also läuft keine Firewall-Geschichte mehr drauf.
Internetzugang geht da auch nicht mehr drüber.
Fernsehaufzeichnungen und sowas.
Mit TV-Karte läuft da auch nicht mehr drüber.
Das ist einfach viel zu viel Single-Point-of-Failure.
Ich habe das mittlerweile mehr aufgesplittet.
Also Raspberry Pi im Keller für die Heizung.
Und für die Tür-Gegen-Sprechanlage im Wohnzimmer.
So eine Linux-Kiste für Fernsehkram.
Die dann quasi streamt an Shield-TV.
Und so Sachen.
Ich habe das in einem der letzten Streams ja mal aufgemalt.
Aber jetzt mal fertig gucken.
Done.
You should also make sure your...
Alter, diesen Kabeltester, den hat jeder, oder?
Das ist glaube ich der 0815 China-Chinesen-Kabeltester, den jeder irgendwann mal irgendwie in der Hand hatte.
Sag mal, wie viele von euch haben bzw. hatten diesen Kabeltester schon mal in der Hand?
Das ist so der billigste Einstiegskabeltester ever.
Jeder.
Genau dieses Teil, ey.
Die Dinger sind übrigens gar nicht gut.
Muss man, muss man ja echt mal sagen.
Das Einzige, was diese Teile können, ist zu checken.
Und noch nicht mal.
Die können noch nicht mal das.
Du musst selbst checken.
Mit Auge.
Du musst Auge, Auge machen.
Selbst da drauf.
Ob die Streifen parallel alle richtig leuchten, der macht gar nichts, dieser Kabeltester.
Also wenn man wirklich ordentlich Kabel testen will, gibt es schon recht günstige, deutlich bessere Kabeltester.
Die dann auch testen können.
So wie heißt das?
Übersprechen nennt sich das auf Deutsch.
Irgendwelche Tester.
Also ist das nicht so, dass wenn ein Kabel geht, dann geht es auch.
Das ist wie bei vielen Sachen.
Meistens sind Kabelprobleme, wenn wirklich was ganz kaputt ist, geht oder geht nicht.
Aber du kannst ja beispielsweise auch die Isolierung an einer Stelle kaputt gemacht haben.
Und du hast dann Probleme ab einer gewissen Reichweite.
Oder hast nicht mehr diese Gelegenheit.
Oder hast nicht mehr die Signalqualität, die du gerne hättest.
Du weißt ja im Endeffekt nicht, wo es dran liegt.
Dein PoE funktioniert nicht und du weißt nicht warum.
Gibt ja schon mehrere Möglichkeiten, als geht nicht.
Auch bei Kabeln.
Was ist denn das da?
Ist das eine USB-Festplatte?
Ist das überhaupt möglich?
Das erinnert mich an die Torte von Smurgoz.
Das ist Layer upon Layer.
USB-Festplatte.
Wo ist auch noch eine USB-Festplatte?
Was ist denn das?
Das ist eine USB-Festplatte.
Wo ist auch noch eine USB-Festplatte?
Wo kam um die Mülldust her?
awakens dieser
Not
sie
am
oder
bei mir
weiß
dass
dabei nicht
es
da drinnen? Irgendwo?
Wenn man die sieht.
Ja.
Ah, ne, hier war ich gerade am Umbauen.
Ich hab da auch ne Schublade drinnen,
die man rein rausziehen kann.
Da steht zum Beispiel
die Fritzbox drinnen und
der Router.
Die sind halt einfach nicht 19 Zoll, bauweise.
Achso, die
USB-Festplatte. Find ich jetzt nicht schlimm,
wenn die ihm reichen. Ich bin der Meinung,
man muss da pragmatisch sein und es nicht
übertreiben. Warum, wenn ich
einfach nachts mit AirSync
mal nen Backup ziehen will auf eine externe
Platte, warum will ich mir
19 Zoll Storage-Zeug da reinhängen?
Macht ja keinen Sinn, externe Platte, gut ist.
Man muss es nicht
übertreiben.
Oftmals ist einfach und nicht
so ausfallsicher unter
dem Strich in der Summe doch ausfallsicherer.
Versteht
man, was ich meine? Weil
um was ordentlich ausfallsicher zu machen,
ist deutlich erhöhte
Komplexität gefragt, meistens.
Zumindest. Und durch diese
deutlich erhöhte Komplexität
steigt die Chance, dass man selbst
Fehler macht, was dann zu Ausfällen
führt. Und du kannst
dich natürlich so gut wie gar nicht
durch
Bedienfehler-Ausfälle schützen.
Du kannst dich vor Hardware-Fehler-Ausfälle
schützen. Also wenn du sagst,
okay, ich hab Angst, dass
mein Server ausfällt und der Service
dann weg ist,
dann fängst du an mit, okay, ich muss ein Cluster
bauen. Baust ein Cluster mit zwei Kisten,
mit zwei Netzteilen drinnen und dann
stellst du fest, na eigentlich
sind zwei Cluster eher blöd. Es muss
eigentlich mindestens drei Nodes in so einem Cluster
sein. Und wie verbinde ich das
jetzt? Ja, über einen Switch ist ja doof.
Wenn der Switch weg ist, dann denken alle, es ist ein
Master. Das heißt, ich brauche so eine Art Internet
Connect, äh, nicht Internet
Connect, Interconnect. Am besten natürlich
mit extra Netzwerkkarte nochmal
und untereinander verbunden, am besten
doppelt miteinander verbunden. Und dann
endest du dann im Endeffekt mit einem Drei-Node-Cluster,
den du schön mit
einzelnen Netzwerkkarten, Netzwerkkabel miteinander
verbunden hast, verkonfigurierst irgendwas,
die Dinger haben eine doppelte IP und es funktioniert
nicht. Oder irgendwie, also
du hast dann im Endeffekt
mehr Ausfall dadurch,
als wenn du eine Kiste
hingestellt hättest, einmal nächtlich
ein Backup ziehst und wenn die Kiste
wirklich mal kaputt geht,
du dir bei Amazon eine neue Kiste bestellst,
Tag später ist die da,
einbaust, Backup restorest
und gut ist. Ja, da hast du zwei Tage
Ausfall, okay, ja, mag sein.
Ist aber oftmals bei den Sachen
jetzt, wenn man es ein bisschen dezentral
gebaut hat bei sich daheim, dass nicht alles
auf einer zentralen Kiste drauf ist.
Nicht so wild.
Also wenn jetzt mal meine
Heimautomatisierung zwei Tage nicht geht, ist das
wirklich sehr ärgerlich.
An einigen Stellen aber jetzt nicht
lebensnotwendig.
Dann kriege ich nicht angezeigt,
wie viel Verspätung der Zug hat.
Ich kann nicht den Druck
meiner Heizung nachgucken, ich kann nicht den Druck
meiner Heizung automatisch
das Ventil aufmachen
übers Tablet und sowas. Ja, das ist doof,
aber ich kann
beispielsweise auch mein Licht
hier oben an der Decke nicht mehr
gescheit steuern und
dem, aber da komme ich mal zwei Tage
mit aus
und dann ist die Ersatzkiste
da, ich stöpsel
die Festplatten um und es läuft wieder.
Und sollte sich irgendwas da problematisch sein,
ziehe ich mir die Sachen von der externen Platte
als Backup. Das wirkt
irgendwie billig, ich weiß,
das wirkt nicht super technik
sophisticated und advanced,
aber unterm Strich behaupte ich mal,
dass die meisten Leute mit sowas,
obwohl es ein rechnerisch
höheres Risiko hat,
kaputt zu gehen,
praktisch weniger haben, weil
die meisten Leute rechnen ja nur
Hardware Failure Rates mit ein
in das Risiko.
Aber eigentlich müsstest du ja da auch
ich bin zu doof es bedienen
Fehler Rates mit einrechnen.
And Purposes?
What the hell is this thing doing?
Hahaha
Ja, falsch rum.
Oh Gott, is that a reflection of me there?
Gepatcht.
I don't think it's enough, it's not enough of a reflection
to censor.
I love robot vacuum cleaners.
I love robot vac...
Guck mal, das ist ein
Robocock S5.
Sieht zumindest ein bisschen so aus.
So einen hatte ich auch mal. Benutze
ich aber nicht mehr. Ist auch so ein Ding.
Wo ich festgestellt habe,
dass es mehr Arbeit
macht, als es bringt.
Staubsaugerroboter.
Ich bin immer noch in der Versuchung es
mal zu testen mit
einem neuen, der eine Entleerstation
also eine automatische Absaugestation
hat. Weil was mich da rein
immer genervt hat ist, der braucht ja
mehrere Fahrten, bis der den
kompletten Stock hier sauber gemacht hat.
Der ist lahm
und die mehreren
Fahrten kann er nicht machen, weil du zwischendrin leeren kannst.
Und
mir macht es
weniger Gedanken
und weniger Arbeit
einfach ab und zu hier mal mit so einem
ganz klassischen Staubsauger durchzuflitzen
eine Viertelstunde, als
das Ding permanent
zu entleeren und
zu gucken, ob er nicht dann vielleicht
doch am Sessel hängt oder so.
Ja, das ist ein Flaktal Design Gehäuse.
Das ist aber noch ein älteres,
weil das noch kein USB-C
hat, hier.
Also die neueren haben hier ein USB-C.
Was das ist, weiß ich beim besten
Willen nicht. Ist das vielleicht der Reset-Knopf?
Und die neuen haben auch
einen viereckigen Knopf, keinen runden
mehr.
Ich kann doch gucken, ich habe doch das alte
Flaktal Design hier noch stehen. Das ist der Reset-Knopf.
Das ist der Reset-Knopf.
Ja, ich habe nämlich
genau das hier neben mir stehen.
Das ist noch mein altes Case.
Das neue hat jetzt einen viereckigen
Knopf. Aber das ist auch kein Fractal Design.
Ähm,
wie heißt das Ding? R5 oder so?
Mehr? Sondern das ist jetzt ein Mesh.
Fractal Design Mesh irgendwas, was
ich habe. Da, wo die Wasserkühlung reinpasst.
Ja.
Bisschen älteres noch.
Not bad. This was the initial plan
at least. Temporarily.
Thought through.
With my Photoshop picture here.
Pretty good. Pretty good.
Always plan ahead.
After a month
it finally arrived.
All the way from the blessed lands
of China. My new
router.
Okay.
They also sent our power brick
maracas.
Wetten? Der hat sich den gekauft, weil
Surf the Home, das auf YouTube
vorgestellt hat letztens,
brauche ich auch ein nicer Channel.
Der stellt ja immer solche Mini-PCs
vor, die sich gut für Rauter
eignen.
Surf the Home
YouTube.
Guter Channel, wenn man auf so Heimnetzwerk
und Heim
Homelab Sachen steht.
Der untersucht die Dinger immer ziemlich
genau
und
die Dinger, die der empfiehlt,
finde ich meistens auch gut.
Ich habe die Seite schon lange gelesen
früher, bevor die einen YouTube Channel haben.
Die sind ja auch erst seit 2-3 Jahren oder so auf YouTube.
Aber ist ein guter Channel.
Für so kleine Heimserver
oder kleine selbstgebauten Netzwerksachen
und sowas.
Finde ich nice.
Insight Microtex New
2,5 N4G
Guck mal, die haben 9.
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Das sieht doch tatsächlich...
Moment.
Das sind immer noch
20 normale Gigabits, oder?
Das sind keine
Zwug, oder? Oder?
Das könnte tatsächlich ein sehr interessanter
Switch
bzw. Router Switch
wie das Mikrotex nennt
sein.
Kostet.
Äh.
Aber wenn das alles 2,4 G...
Das ist preislich
gar nicht mal schlecht.
25 Ports 2,5 G.
Ähm.
Dann hast du 4 Ports
10 G.
Das ist preislich gar nicht so schlecht,
weil ich vermute auch,
dass es nicht die allerschlechteste
Hardwareausstattung sein wird.
Was ist denn da drinne?
Ja, okay.
Es ist nicht die ganz miese CPU.
Ja, das ist eigentlich
ganz, ganz brauchbar.
Ich mein, für jetzt...
Wenn du da viel mitmachen möchtest
in RouterOS, wenn du da irgendwie planst
600 Firewall Regeln drin zu haben oder so.
Dann ist es vielleicht
nicht unbedingt der Beste.
Aber für den Heimbereich
mehr als ausreichend, ja.
Wenn man das braucht, ja.
Aber im Heimbereich ist wahrscheinlich
20 Ports 2,5 G auch schon
kompletter Overkill.
Ich bin echt zufrieden mit meinem
Edge-Switch.
Den ich seit ein paar Jahren habe.
Also 10 Gigabit.
Ist aber glaube ich echt
eine ganz interessante Kiste.
Gerade für Leute, die eventuell
wirklich auch schon auf 40 G schielen
und 2,5 Gig Geräte haben.
Mal Frage an euch, weil ich glaube,
dass es überhaupt nicht verbreitet ist.
Wie viele 2,5 Gig Geräte
habt ihr?
Also ich habe 2.
Mein neuer Rechner
und mein alter...
Mein neuer Desktop Rechner
und mein alter Desktop Rechner.
Der alte
Onboard tatsächlich.
Mein alter Desktop Rechner hat 10 Gig
Onboard.
Mein neuer hat halt
eine Karte drin, die das könnte.
Aber muss er nicht.
Er ist per 10 Gig angebunden.
Also ich habe auch nur 2 Geräte.
Der Rest ist alles noch Oldschool Gigabit.
Und ich bilde mir sogar ein,
ich habe noch irgendein uraltes 100 Mbit
Gerät. Ich weiß aber gerade nicht,
was es ist.
Raspberry Pi 3?
Waren die schon
Gig oder 100
Mbit Netzwerk?
Die waren schon Gigabit, gell?
Ich bilde mir ein, ich habe letztens
100 Mbit hier nochmal
Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Fällt mir jetzt nichts ein.
Whatever. Dann habe ich doch
kein 100 Mbit mehr.
Was war das für ein Mainboard mit 100 Mbit?
Kann ich dir sagen. Ich habe doch ein Video dazu.
So, nicht mein neuer Rechner.
Der hat das nämlich nicht. Mein alter Rechner.
Mein neuer Rechner?
Ist es der?
Ne, warte mal. Vor 10 Jahren?
Ne.
Das ist noch ein älterer.
Dazwischen müsste es noch ein Video
gegeben haben.
Das ist der Xeon gewesen.
Wenn jetzt,
wisst ihr was geil wäre?
Eine ordentliche Suche auf Youtube.
Der da.
Der da ist es. Der hat
ein
S-Rock Fatality Z370
Professional, Leute.
Professional Gaming.
Und der hat Onboard eine 10 Gigabit
Card, äh 10 Gigabit
NIC.
gehabt.
Hier.
Und das schon vor
Urzeiten gefühlt.
Ich weiß nicht, warum es so wenig Rechner gibt,
die das heutzutage haben.
Ja und die kann halt auch alles dazwischen.
Also in der Regel können 10 Gigabit Karten auch immer alles dazwischen.
Also 1, 2,5 und 5.
Ob die Dinger noch
mit 100 sinken, weiß ich nicht.
Also ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob eine aktuelle Netzwerkkarte da noch
10 Mbit oder 100 Mbit sinken würde.
Ja die
wollen so ähnlich klingen, aber Fatality ist
der ehemalige Quake Spieler.
Der glaub ich auch Twitch
streamt mittlerweile.
Der hat schon Business gemacht zu Zeiten.
Also mit Gaming schon Business
gemacht. Da haben die ganzen Leute,
die heute was von Gaming Business erzählen noch in die
Windel geschissen.
Das war eines der ersten richtig bekannten
Pro Gamer.
Der damit auch richtig Kohle gemacht hat,
der an, ich glaub erstmal an Creative
oder so, die
Namensrechte verkauft hat, um
mit seinem, ja
eigentlich Nickname
Produkte rauszubringen und
irgendwie ging es dann an ASRock vielleicht.
Der hat an Ferrari gewonnen oder
keine Ahnung. Möglich.
Jetzt gucken wir das aber nochmal schnell fertig.
Was haben wir?
2,5, 4
2,5 Gig Ports
Ich persönlich
bin ja weggekommen von
selbst
gebauten, beziehungsweise selbst
installierten Routern.
Seitdem ich mein Billig
Mikrotik Router habe
brauche
ich das nicht. Der ist
günstig
und der hat mit
Router OS so ziemlich alle nur
eigentlichen Features, die man so brauchen
kann von einem Netzwerkgerät.
In einem Web Interface.
In einem
etwas gewöhnungsbedürftigen
Web Interface.
Router OS Demo.
Also so sieht
die Oberfläche von Mikrotik Geräten aus.
Die erschlägt einen komplett.
Ja.
Also das erschlägt
einen wirklich. Aber du kannst damit
nahezu alles, was
du machen willst, machen.
Natürlich, wenn du ganz
abgedrehte Sonderdinger machen möchtest
ist eine Linux Kiste,
wo du komplett freie Hand hast, immer noch am
besten. Aber
so spontan fällt mir wenig
ein, was du nicht machen könntest
mit so einem Mikrotik Router OS
Gerät. Unter der Haube läuft da
auch übrigens irgendein Linux.
Aber du kriegst halt hier
ein ganz brauchbares Web Interface
um die Sachen zu konfigurieren.
Und du hast ja auch
hier Terminal Access und sowas.
Darf man jetzt hier nicht machen.
Und
man bekommt auch
für Noobs zur initialen
Einrichtung kann man auch hier so
einen Quick Setup machen.
Aber wer ein bisschen advancedere Sachen machen möchte
mit seinem Netzwerk, mit seinem Router,
mit seinen Netzwerk Geräten, sind die Router OS
Dinger von Mikrotik wirklich gut.
Weil das ist günstig. Der Hex PoE
kostet 50 Euro oder so. Den gibt's
ja gar nicht mehr. Nur mal
Beispielsweise.
Okay, gibt's noch. Aber gibt's noch.
Neueres Modell von.
Das ist das Ding was ich hab hier als Router.
Hat damals 50 Euro gekostet.
Du bekommst
4, äh sogar 5
5 PoE, ne 4.
4 PoE, 1 Gig Ports.
Dann noch
einen normalen SFP Port,
einen 1 Gig Port, das du aber glaube ich
nicht zusammen verwenden kannst.
Ach ne, der hat PoE
in. So rum war das. Ah ja, genau.
Also man könnte den Router selbst
wiederum per
Betreiben.
Dass da Internet dran steht, ist komplett
bescheuert. Du kannst die Ports so
konfigurieren wie du willst.
Und das ist die Oberfläche von dem Ding.
Also so sieht Router OS bei allen Mikrotik Geräten aus.
Und das ist ein 50 Euro Router.
Der macht alles was ich will.
Kann 1000 mal mehr als ich bräuchte.
Hat SSH Access,
Terminal Access, Web Interface.
PoE.
PoE kriegst du ja prinzipiell bei selbstgebautem Router
nicht.
Es ist für mich echt so
sorglos Ding.
Es ist ein bisschen kompliziert.
Das gebe ich zu.
Gerade die WLAN Config ist super weird.
Da muss ich auch immer nachgucken.
WLAN Config kannst du bei
Mikrotik ja auf 5 verschiedene Arten machen.
Äh
Warte mal.
Bridge WLANs.
Dann kannst du auf die Interfaces
irgendwie gehen.
WLANs. Und dann gibt es noch irgendwo
einen eigenen WLAN Punkt.
Der ist dann aber unter
Keine Ahnung wo der sich versteckt.
Da gibt es irgendwie.
Ne Interfaces ist es.
Das habe ich gesucht.
Also das ist.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung
wie man es schafft WLAN Settings
so kompliziert zu machen.
WLAN Settings sind eigentlich was relativ
simples.
Gibt zwei Varianten.
Entweder ist das ein Trunk Port.
So wie Cisco das nennen würde.
Port heißt das da glaube ich.
Also im Prinzip ist der Unterschied.
Es ist ein Port.
Wo automatisch
wenn Traffic rein geht.
Internen WLAN Tag drauf kommt.
Und wieder entfernt wird beim raus gehen.
Weil die Endgeräte nichts mit WLANs anfangen können.
Das ist der Standard Modus.
Eigentlich.
Und dann gibt es quasi Trunk Ports.
Die sind von
Netzwerkgerät zu Netzwerkgerät
Kommunikation gedacht.
Wo Traffic drüber läuft. Der getaggt ist.
In verschiedenste WLANs.
Also im Prinzip gibt es die zwei Sachen.
Und die einfachste Variante ist.
Ich glaube ein Tagged Port heißt das bei Cisco.
Das ist die ganz klassische WLAN Konfiguration.
Die man kennt.
Wo man sagt.
Dieser Port soll in WLAN
und fertig.
Das bedeutet dann.
Das jeglicher Traffic der dort rein geht.
An diesem Port getaggt wird.
Mit WLAN 1337.
Für die weitere.
Bearbeitung in den Netzwerkgeräten.
Und so jeder Traffic der raus geht.
An diesem Port dann.
Das WLAN Tag wieder entfernt kriegt.
Weil die Endgeräte damit nichts anfangen können.
Die haben es super kompliziert gemacht.
Hier bei MikroTik.
Oder Untagged.
Ich meine halt das ganz normale Konfig.
Dieser Port bekommt WLAN Tag XY.
Und dann gibt es ja noch die Kombination.
Da gibt es ja noch ein bisschen die Kombination aus beidem.
Du kannst ja auch einen Trunk Port machen.
Mit einem Default WLAN Port.
Mit einem Default WLAN Tag.
Wobei ich dann nicht weiß.
Ob das streng genommen.
Da müssen wir unseren ganzen Cisco Experts hier helfen.
Oder Access Port heißt es.
Ja kann sein.
Du kannst ja auch sagen.
Hier geht getaggter WLAN Traffic drüber.
Alles was angetaggt ist.
Soll in das und das Default WLAN.
Das gibt es ja auch noch.
So eine Kombi Variante.
Die IP Telefonen.
Die sich erstmal ihre Konfig ziehen.
Das ist angetaggter Traffic.
Aber das Gerät selbst.
Versteht dann WLANs.
Nachdem es mal konfiguriert ist.
Nachdem es gebootet ist über DHCP oder so.
Also du sagst dann einfach hier.
Dieser Port hat Default WLAN 5.
Aber selbst erlaubt es da drüber.
Getaggter WLAN Traffic in Port 1337.
Zu gehen.
Und dann macht das IP Telefon.
Macht dann DHCP.
WLAN 5 gepackt.
WLAN 5 steht dann auch der DHCP Server.
Das Ding bootet mit einer IP.
Und dann macht es den VoIP Traffic.
Über WLAN 1337.
Und taggt das selbst.
Die Kombinationsmöglichkeiten gibt es auch noch.
Ja.
Zumindest.
So sieht das MikroTik Ding aus.
Und nachdem du nie PoE bekommst.
In so fertige Dinger.
Finde ich das ein super Kompromiss.
Es hat bei weitem nicht die Power.
Von so einer Kiste.
Aber an der Stelle brauche ich ja auch nicht mehr.
50 Euro.
Schön passiv gekühlt auch.
Nachdem da ein Linux drauf gehauen wird.
Wird mir früher oder später.
Eher noch irgendwelche Spielereien drauf hauen.
Bin mir nicht sicher.
Kann man bei OpenSense oder PFSense.
Mittlerweile.
Container drauf laufen lassen.
Wenn man Bock hat.
Ich persönlich würde ja hoffen.
Nein dass das nicht geht.
Weil die sollten sich darauf konzentrieren.
Eine stabile Firewall Netzwerk Distribution.
Bereitzustellen.
Ohne irgendwelches komische.
Containermanagement noch drauf.
6 GB Storage.
For some reason.
Out with the old.
Wobei.
Ist das nicht sogar BSD.
Ist OpenSense und PFSense.
Nicht sogar BSD.
Dann fällt das mit Linux Containern eh flach.
Ich glaube das ist BSD.
Ja dann vergisst was ich gesagt habe.
Ich meine Docker funktioniert.
Glaube ich.
Auch unter BSD.
Wobei es dort selbstverständlich.
Keine Linux Container startet.
Sondern halt eine eigene.
Container BSD Runtime hat.
Die dann wahrscheinlich irgendwas BSD.
Native mäßiges verwendet.
Ja doch.
Wenn es kein Linux ist.
Erinnert mich da schon was dran.
Es sei denn es gibt halt alles was ich dafür brauche.
Auch für BSD.
Keine Erfahrung mit Docker unter BSD.
Ich meine wenn Docker.
Wenn es eine OCI oder so.
Kompatible Container Runtime.
Für BSD gibt.
Dann geht das auch.
Kenne ich mich aber nicht mit aus.
Der Noctua Lüft.
Der beste.
Ich finde.
Ich finde übrigens.
Ich mag so.
Pragmatische.
Ich hoffe man sieht den.
Ich mag so.
Pragmatische Sachen.
Wie deine Lüfter reinstellen.
Das einzige Problem was ich damit sehe ist.
Das das nicht.
Staub dicht ist.
Und gerade drum herum.
Und sowas hier hat immer viele Lücken.
Das wird verstaubt sein.
Ich habe glücklicherweise in meinem Serverraum.
Nicht so sehr das Problem.
Weil das echt ein abgeschlossener.
Raum mit Tür ist.
Da kommt nicht so viel Staub rein.
Der nicht schon drin ist.
Und da ist wenig Staub drin.
Ihr habt es ja hier gesehen.
In dem alten Video.
Die Kiste hier unten.
Die am Anfang auf dem Boden stand.
Ja genau.
Die Kiste.
Die stand mehrere Jahre in diesem Serverraum.
Und ihr seht kaum Staub.
Warum soll ich eine Kiste die ich ausbaue sauber machen.
Kaum Staub.
Also ist tatsächlich wenig drin.
Da muss auf jeden Fall.
Also wenn das ein Lüfter ist.
Der mit der Außenwelt.
Mit dem äußeren Raum.
Um diesen Schrank.
Da muss ein Staubfilter hin.
Ohne Staubfilter ist das Ding.
Nach einem Jahr.
So eingestaubt.
Das du das nicht verwenden willst.
Deswegen sagt man ja auch.
Ich muss jetzt nochmal unterbrechen.
Wenn man ein Gehäuse mit Lüftern ausstattet.
Sollte man immer gucken.
Das ein Überdruck.
Heißt das oder.
Im Gehäuse ist.
Also du solltest immer mehr Lüfter haben.
Das Gehäuse.
Reinblasen.
Als Lüfter die es rausziehen.
Das heißt du hast ein bisschen Überdruck im Gehäuse.
Das heißt es kommt kein Staub von außen rein.
Sofern die Lüfter.
Die die Luft reinziehen.
Staubfilter davor haben logisch.
Also es sollten immer.
Ein bisschen mehr Lüfter sein.
Die Luft reinpusten.
Als Luft die rausgepustet wird.
Weil umgedreht.
Wenn du.
Lüfter hast die.
Die Luft aus dem Gehäuse rausziehen.
Und erzeugt das.
Ein Unterdruck.
Im Gehäuse.
Das heißt.
Du solltest immer mehr Lüfter.
Reinpusten.
Als rauspusten.
Weil wenn du mehr Lüfter hast.
Die die Luft aus dem Gehäuse rausziehen.
Und erzeugt das.
Ein Unterdruck.
Im Gehäuse.
Das heißt.
Du solltest immer mehr Lüfter.
Reinpusten.
Wenn du.
Lüfter hast.
Die Luft aus dem Gehäuse rausziehen.
Wenn du.
Lüfter hast.
Die Luft aus dem Gehäuse rausziehen.
Und erzeugt das.
Ein Unterdruck.
Wenn du.
Lüfter hast.
Die Luft aus dem Gehäuse rausziehen.
Wenn du.
Lüfter hast.
Die Luft aus dem Gehäuse rausziehen.
Wenn du.
Lüfter hast.
Die Luft aus dem Gehäuse.
Wenn du.
Lüfter hast.
Die Luft aus dem Gehäuse rausziehen.
Und erzeugt das.
Ein Unterdruck.
Im Gehäuse.
Die UV Oberfläche.
Regisseur.
queries.
Ich habe nur gute Erfahrungen mit AliExpress bisher gemacht.
Ist da ein Staubfilter davor oder nicht? Wenn nicht, ist das Ding so schnell voller Staub.
Da ist kein Staubfilter davor, oder? Man sieht es nicht richtig, aber wenn da keiner
davor ist, dann ist das so, dass, wie gesagt, ich gebe dem Ding keine Ahnung, ein dreiviertel
Jahr oder so, ist das Ding komplett eingestaubt.
Es ist in dem Fall egal, ob das rein- oder rauszieht. Das, was ich eben gesagt habe,
mit dem Überdruck im Gehäuse, das funktioniert nur, wenn die Lüfter, die die Luft reinsaugen,
einen Staubfilter davor haben. Wie läuft das eigentlich mit Zoll bei AliExpress? AliExpress
macht das geschickt im Vergleich zu, wenn du Sachen aus den USA bestellst. AliExpress
schickt das zuerst nach...
...
...in die Niederlande irgendwo. Und von dort geht es dann weiter innerhalb der EU per DHL
oder per whatever, meistens DHL. Oder Post. PostNL übernimmt manchmal auch noch ein bisschen
den Weitertransport, aber hier letztendlich kommt dann die Post oder das DHL-Auto. Und
dadurch, dass das dann quasi EU-Traffic ist, ist dann eh mit Zoll nichts. Die machen die
dann am Hafen in den Niederlanden. Und anscheinend sind die deutlich besser als die Amis mit dem...
...mit den ganzen Papieren, weil ich hatte noch nie Zollprobleme mit den China-Chinesen.
Bei den Amis jedes Mal, wenn ich aus den USA bestellt habe, deswegen bestelle ich nicht
mehr aus den USA, jedes Mal Zollprobleme. Am schlimmsten war der Zoll in Leipzig oder
beziehungsweise DHL, die sich um den Zoll in Leipzig kümmern kann. Hab ich angerufen,
hab die gefragt, wie es aussieht. Und dann meinten sie, das kann ich ihnen auch nun nüscht's.
sagen. Nüscht's. Nüscht's sagen, kann ich ihnen das. Nüscht's sagen. Ach ja gut, schön,
dass ich angerufen hab. Und die Chinesen kriegen das besser hin. Wie auch immer die das machen,
vielleicht schreiben die auch einfach Bullshit drauf, der nicht stimmt, womit die Zoll-Leute
dann zufrieden sind. Oder es ist schlicht und ergreifend so viel auf diesen Container-Chefen
drauf, dass sie das Pi mal Daumen machen. So, ah ja, wird schon passen.
.
Hat noch ganz ordentlich gemacht, wie gesagt ich mach mir nur ein bisschen Gedanken über
Staub da drinne.
Chat, ich hab, ich bin, alter, wie bin ich bitteschön schon 3 Stunden 15 on? Wir haben
zwei Videos geguckt oder so.
.
Wieso?
Wie hat denn das wieder funktioniert?
Oder drei? Drei Videos.
Hast du deine... Ne, hab ich nicht. Wo denn?
Wie unterscheidet es uns zwischen...
Poste nochmal, ich guck gleich.
Wie unterscheidet es uns zwischen gutem, absoluten und schlechtem?
Das ist eine...
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Ich würde es mal als Bauchgefühl
zusammenfassen.
Also ich guck mir auch ein bisschen die Bewertung an,
wobei da bei AliExpress wenig drauf geben
kannst.
Schwer zu sagen, echt schwer zu sagen,
woran ich das an AliExpress
festmache.
Also ich guck mir halt an, wie die
Anzahl, also wie die... AliExpress,
muss man ja wissen, AliExpress ist ja quasi ein großer
Marketplace mit ganz vielen Shops
drin. AliExpress selbst verkauft ja da nix.
Also
glaub ich zumindest. Also das meiste sind Shops.
Also ich guck mir an
ein bisschen, wie die
Shop-Seite so aussieht und
ähm...
Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist das Bauchgefühl.
Wenn ich mir denke, ja,
sieht nicht total billig und unprofessionell
aus, dann klappt das meistens.
Und ich hab schon recht...
Also ich mein, ich hab jetzt keine tausend Sachen
oder so, keine Sample-Size
von tausend Bestellungen, wo ich sagen kann,
tausend Sachen bestellt und
995 ohne Probleme.
Nee, ich hab vielleicht insgesamt
so, weiß nicht, 50, 60 Sachen
oder so bei AliExpress bestellt.
Und so richtig große
Probleme hatte ich noch nie.
Ich hatte einmal eine Bestellung, die kam nicht an.
Aber da hat AliExpress
sehr schnell drauf reagiert
und mein Geld zurück überwiesen.
Und mit viel weniger Problemen, als ich
mit dem PayPal-Käuferschutz hatte.
Weil AliExpress hat das umgedreht.
AliExpress hat einfach gesagt,
wenn man als Kunde nicht nach
48 Stunden sagt, ja, es wurde
zu meiner
Zufriedenheit gelöst, kriegst du einfach dein Geld zurück.
Nicht so wie bei PayPal. Ah, sie haben nicht
reagiert, Case geschlossen.
AliExpress hat den Verkauf... AliExpress...
Also, Problem war, ich hab was bestellt,
die haben mir eine Versandnummer, äh,
Tracking-Nummer bestellt, jetzt hat sich einfach nichts getan.
Ja, bestimmt eine Woche war nichts getan.
Hab ich da hingeschrieben, hab gesagt, oh, sorry, ja,
hier haben sie eine neue Tracking-Nummer.
Die neue Tracking-Nummer war ja die alte Tracking-Nummer
und wo sich dann wieder ein paar Tage nichts getan hat.
Dann hab ich an den AliExpress-Käuferschutz
äh, geschrieben
und die haben gesagt,
okay, sie kontaktieren den Verkäufer.
Dann haben sie geschrieben, ja,
Verkäufer wurde kontaktiert, ähm,
bitte sagen sie Bescheid,
innerhalb von 48 Stunden,
ob sich das Problem
erledigt hat.
Problem hat sich nicht erledigt, weil die haben mir nochmal
die gleiche Tracking-Nummer geschickt, wo sich nichts getan hat
und haben gesagt, äh, bitte
haben sie noch etwas Geduld.
Und da hab ich einfach mal gedacht, okay, was passiert dann,
wenn ich nicht reagiere? Hab ich 48 Stunden
nicht reagiert, AliExpress hat das Ding
geclosed und mir mein Geld
zurücküberwiesen.
Und die Sendung kam auch nie an.
Das heißt, die haben mir von Anfang an
Bullshit erzählt, von wegen, es wär schon in der Zeit.
Ja, das war das einzige
Problem, was ich je hatte. Ansonsten, ich hab 50, 60
Sachen da oder so schon bestellt.
Also Bestellung, nicht Sachen. Sachen insgesamt mehr.
50, 60 Mal oder so, da bestellt
schon. Und außer
einmal, das hatte nie Probleme.
Ich hab da aber auch nur Technik-Zeug
bestellt. Ich hab da noch nie, ja, du kannst ja
bei AliExpress den größten Bullshit bestellen,
ja, von, äh, Hair Extensions
äh, zu
äh, keine Ahnung,
gefälschten Zähnen
oder so. Alles. Es gibt auch,
auf AliExpress, die
wirsten Sachen, ja.
Oder du kannst ja auch bei AliExpress auch so
medizinische Geräte bestellen. Da gibt es Geräte,
die, äh, sollen dir
angeblich Muttermale
rausschneiden können. Alter, wer sich
sowas kauft bei AliExpress
und benutzt, ist lebensmüde.
Also das ist einfach nur dämlich.
Da gehst du zum Hautarzt,
wenn du Probleme hast, aber bestellst du nicht bei
AliExpress einen Muttermale-Entferner.
Aber Microcontroller, Technik-Zeug,
ich hab mir bei AliExpress,
auch mal, ein 50er-Pack
USB-Kabel bestellt, kam an, ohne
Probleme. Jetzt kann man sich natürlich
fragen, Max, was willst du mit
50 USB-Kabeln?
Da muss ich euch leider sagen, ich weiß es bis heute
selbst nicht so genau.
Also ich hab davon bestimmt noch 40
rumliegen, die ich nie gebraucht hab, aber
die sind da. 50er-Pack, ja.
Aber für
genau sowas ist AliExpress gut.
Zum Beispiel 50 USB-C.
Das ist, das ist einfach
verlosen. Was muss denn da verlosen?
Alter.
Und das ist halt echt konkurrenzlos
billig. Guck mal hier. Du bestellst,
du kannst dir hier
50 1 Meter
USB-Kabel bestellen.
Nein, nein, nein, das sind 50.
Und
das kostet 23 Euro.
Das sind 50 Cent pro USB-Kabel.
Und nachdem die
meisten USB-Kabel, die du dir bei Amazon
so bestellen kannst, auch China-Chinesen-Kram
sind, sind die wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal so viel
schlechter als die nur auf 15 USB-Kabel.
Von Amazon.
So, 100 Kosten.
Ja, ist doppelt ungefähr.
Ah, die, die
weltbekannte Marke
AEVVKIF.
Alles klar.
Wer kennt sie nicht?
AEVVKIF.
Bestellen bitte. Ne, brauche ich nicht.
Ich hab noch genug USB-Kabel. Ich hab mir damals
ein 50er-Pack bestellt.
Micro-USB-USBC-Kombokabel.
Ich glaube, ich hab
die auch nicht so oft verwendet, weil ich die
die Buchse
vorne kacke finde mit dieser
extra Sache für USB-C.
Vielleicht soll ich mir nochmal ein 50er-Pack USB-C
bestellen. Aber ich hab
ich hab einfach, ich hab schon mehr als
ich hab ne komplette Schublade
voll mit USB-Kabel. Und das ist eine
große Schublade. Das ist quasi eher
so ein alter Amazon-Karton voll.
Da sind bestimmt, keine Ahnung, 250
USB-Kabel oder so drin, die
sich mittlerweile angesammelt haben. Ich brauch keine
USB-Kabel. Plus, die, die
Dinger, die ich von AliExpress bestellt hab, die sind
noch in einer anderen Kiste drin.
Freu dich. Also für so Sachen ist AliExpress
unschlagbar günstig.
Und der Kram, und die meinen
das ernst, ja. Der Kram kommt auch immer
ziemlich gut an. Ähm, ihr könnt
sogar filtern bei AliExpress
nach Versand von.
Ja, also man kann hier zum Beispiel,
das ist bei AliExpress immer übelst
beknackt gemacht. Ja, aber hier
man kann sagen, Versand from Germany.
Äh, oder
okay, mein Darkreader macht komische
Dinger. Ja,
du kannst sogar aus EU gucken, ja.
Hier gibt's welche Sachen, die werden von Germany, was auch
immer das mit 50 USB-C jetzt zu tun hat.
Die AliExpress-Suche ist noch
wirrer als die Amazon-Suche.
Also, ich wollt mich schon auch immer
so ne 100 Zoll-Winde bestellen
bei AliExpress. Also, das ist
so ein Ding, also ne Winde,
wo
ich vielleicht selbst mich
dranhänge, weil ich irgendwie da
klettern muss oder so. Die würd ich nicht
unbedingt bei AliExpress bestellen, ja. Also,
alles, wo's um Leben und Tod geht, ist
AliExpress nicht unbedingt
meine erste Wahl.
Oder auch halt
alles, wo's in die Tausende an Schaden
geht, wenn was kaputt geht, ist nicht meine erste Wahl.
Also, zum Beispiel würd ich keine Batterien
bestellen bei AliExpress, ja.
Bei China-Chinesen-Batterien hätt ich viel zu viel
Schiss, dass die mir kaputt gehen und abfackeln.
Ja, da brennt dir die Bude ab, wegen
2 Euro gespart für ne Batterie.
Was, was für nen Widerspruch?
Kann ja mit dem Ladekabel, warum?
Warum?
Bei nem USB-Kabel.
Das ist, das kommt
ne USB-Buchse,
da hast du 5 Volt und
was, was geht da maximal
zum Laden bei so nem, bei so nem ollen Ding?
1, 2 Ampere? Das ist doch
ein bisschen was anderes,
wie, äh,
Akkus, die abfackeln können, oder
gar Sachen, die du irgendwie an 230
Volt betreibst an der Steckdose.
Schon mal Storage auf
AliExpress bestellt? Du meinst SSDs und
sowas? Nee. Nee.
Hab ich nicht.
Vieles ist mittlerweile gar nicht mehr so viel günstiger
auf AliExpress, wie wenn du es dir direkt bei Amazon
kaufst. Storage gehört da glaube
ich mit dazu. Das einzige, was geht,
ist diese super billigen
Drecks-USB-Sticks, die schon mal jeder hatte.
Die es da immer im 100er-Pack gibt.
Diese Dinger, die hatte jeder schon mal.
Chat, Hand hoch, wer diesen
USB-Stick schon mal hatte.
Das sind halt die allergrößten
billig Schrottdinger.
Die haben so 1 KB
pro Sekunde Transferspeed.
Das ist halt
gut. Also, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Anscheinend
das soll ein Holzofen
sein. Ja, die
Beschreibung bei AliExpress ist oftmals
ziemlich, ziemlich merkwürdig.
Das sieht aus wie ein
Heißluftgerät.
Holzofenwerkzeug.
Die China-Chinesen,
die waren alle da.
Nee, das ist doch nicht wahr.
Ist das einfach nur eine hässlich aussehende
Lötkolben oder was ist das?
Ach nee, das ist so, wo du Sachen
irgendwie reingravieren kannst.
Holzofen, Alter.
Ja, da muss man sich bei AliExpress
dran gewöhnen, dass die
Beschriftung ziemlich bescheuert ist oftmals.
Sparkasse verschickt
USB-Sticks.
Ja, in Deutschland sind wir da immer ein bisschen merkwürdig drauf
mit solchen Sachen. Die könnten sich die AGBs auch einfach im Hinterland
angucken. Zumindest eigentlich
mag ich das nicht. Ihr könnt hier mittlerweile
noch nach Land filtern,
wovon das Ganze verschickt wird.
Da könnt ihr euch dann sicher sein, dass das auch pünktlich ankommt.
Ja, also
das ist was, hier wäre ich zum Beispiel
persönlich ein bisschen vorsichtig.
Solche, das sind
ja für Ladegeräte fürs Auto,
die du nur, wenn du einen Anzug an hast,
richtig benutzen kannst.
Da weiß ich nicht so genau, ob ich mich da auf
AliExpress-Sachen verlassen würde.
Das sind,
die meisten Sachen
wären, was sind das, 400 Volt
und bis zu
was ist denn das?
Was macht denn so
eine normale
keine Ahnung
ich glaube 11 Kilowatt
ist so die normale
Ladestation, die man ohne
Genehmigung daheim
haben darf.
Da habe ich ein bisschen
Humanized Design
Eier, okay.
Da hätte ich halt so ein bisschen Bedenken damit,
mit so AliExpress-Dinger mein Elektroauto zu laden.
Also das, das sind so Sachen, da traue ich denen nicht so ganz.
Aber für Elektronik-Kleinteile ist das super.
Ja, wenn man sich hier zum Beispiel,
der Klassiker, ja, irgendein ESP32.
Wobei es sie mittlerweile auch in Deutschland relativ günstig zu kaufen gibt.
Aber die sind halt hier immer noch echt konkurrenzlos günstig.
Wenn man hier mal nach so einem D1 Mini guckt, auf AliExpress, guck mal,
das ist so, hier bezahlst du 6 Euro.
Oder 3,50 Euro pro Ding.
Also wenn man sowas, das ist wirklich konkurrenzlos billig oftmals auf AliExpress sowas.
Wobei das ein Fake D1 Mini ist, das ist ein Feiyan D1 Mini, das ist kein offizieller
Wemos D1 Mini.
Aber, die Dinger tun, ja.
Oder auch wenn man halt irgendwelche Bauteile braucht, ja, also zum Beispiel hier
Ultraschall
Schall
Sensor, ich kann nicht schreiben.
Ultraschall Sensor.
Ja, so Dinger hier.
Das ist unschlagbar günstig.
Bei AliExpress solche Sachen.
Und deswegen kaufe ich auch immer,
ich habe es euch ja schon oft erzählt, ich kaufe keine einzelnen Teile mehr.
Ich kaufe immer nur mindestens 3er Packs.
Und bei AliExpress bei sowas nehme ich auch 5er und 10er Packs.
Weil du da 5 Stück kriegst für das, was du hier einbezahlst.
Hast du eine Idee, wie man am besten die FFmpeg Parameter lernt?
Hätte gerne eine C-Sharp-Web-API, die Videos streamt mit HLS und adaptiert wird im Stream.
Die Examples angucken.
Also du willst ja nicht FFmpeg per Kommandozeile machen, du willst ja die FFmpeg Library verwenden.
Vermutlich mal, ja.
Da hätte ich jetzt so spontan auch gar keine Ahnung, wie ich das machen würde.
Also HLS muss man wahrscheinlich dann über C-Sharp machen.
Man bekommt wahrscheinlich die Video-Häppchen dann von FFmpeg.
Das Streamen müsstest du irgendwie über C-Sharp machen.
Und Adaptive Bitrate, ja, je nachdem was FFmpeg...
Also ich hätte jetzt spontan keine Idee, wie ich es mit FFmpeg bauen würde.
Aber ich würde mir die Examples angucken.
Es gibt von FFmpeg...
Achso, du würdest die CLI verwenden.
Aber wie willst du das dann mit deiner .NET Sache integrieren?
Also ich meine, du brauchst also FFmpeg...
Achso, du willst FFmpeg als Browser starten und sowas.
Ja, das geht, das geht.
Äh, ja, Kommandozeilen-Parameter ist FFmpeg-Extrem-Wir.
Da bleibt nur Stack-Overflow.
Copy-Paste bis es funktioniert.
Okay, Leute, ich habe übelst Hunger.
Ich gehe jetzt was fressen.
Lachs mit Nudel, grüner Sauce.
Reiki, dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich schau mal kurz, ob ich nicht irgendjemanden vergessen habe.
Weil das wollen wir ja nicht.
Daxdan!
Dich habe ich ver...
Du hast nur gefollowt.
Aber...
Erwähnen wir aber trotzdem mal.
Übrigens, wenn euch die Streams gefallen, ich freue mich über jeden Follower.
Ich bin in...
Ich kann nicht mehr reden, Alter.
Ich lasse es bleiben.
Ich wollte sagen, ich bin in nächster Zeit auch wieder öfters on.
Jetzt bin ich auch wieder ganz gesund.
MMO-Kreiselkleid muss trotzdem sein.
Hat jemand aus dem Chat oder eine Idee, an was es liegen kann, dass IPsec performt?
Ja, an IPsec wahrscheinlich.
Auf der PSNC-Proxmox läuft ihr ja auch, ne?
Ähm...
Ja...
Ich vermute mal, dass du nicht auf die Krypto-Extensions deiner CPU...
Und hat deine...
Hat deine CPU überhaupt Krypto-Extensions, je nachdem, worauf du das laufen hast?
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die...
...OM nicht checkt, dass deine CPU Krypto-Extensions hat.
Das kannst du testen mit OpenSSL.
OpenSSL-Benchmark machen.
Und gucken, wie viel durchgeht.
Es gibt bestimmt mittlerweile bessere Tests, ob die Krypto-Extensions...
Mach mal Dings hier.
Mach mal, ähm...
Catproc-CPU-Info.
Auf der VM.
Und dann musst du gucken, ob die Krypto...
Boah, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht, was da von die Krypto-Extensions...
AES irgendwas, hä?
Gibt es hier sowas wie AES?
Soll ich mal eine AES kappen?
Okay, tatsächlich.
Color.
Bin zu dumm.
AES.
Ja, hier.
Ja, sowas musst du gucken.
Wobei ich mich da nicht drauf verlassen würde, dass das auch alles richtig durchgereicht wird dann.
Ja.
Guck, ob deine CPU das hier hat.
Oder das deiner CPU entsprechende.
Wenn die CPU auch AES in der VM hat, dann weiß ich es nicht.
Vielleicht ist das IPsec ohne Krypto-Extensions-Support kompiliert.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Da musst du suchen.
Aber ich würde auf jeden Fall in dieser Richtung mal gucken.
Weil 2,5 GIG quasi Saturated normal.
Und 280 MBit mit Krypto-Exter erscheint mir doch ein wenig sehr wenig.
Der AES-NI heißt das Feature.
In CPU-Flex heißt das glaube ich nur AES.
Bei AMD heißt das glaube ich noch anders.
Und bei ARM-CPUs auch irgendwie anders.
Döner bestellen.
Nein.
Ich futter Lachs mit Nudel und grüner Sauce.
Bis denn, Leute.
Wir hören uns.
Macht's gut.
See you.